Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, ist die AfD jetzt eigentlich schon verboten oder kommt das erst noch?
Nee, aber denen gehen langsam echt die Vertreter aus.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 494 vom 23. Mai 2024.
Und das heißt, wer hat heute Geburtstag? Na? Na? Na?
Das Grundgesetz. Ja, der 23. Mai.
Magische Zahlen. 2, 3, 5.
Du hast einfach nur heute Morgen Zeitung gelesen. Es ist alles voll davon.
Ich wusste das schon immer. Da wird auch immer der Bundespräsident gewählt.
Und wie alt ist es denn geworden?
Hä?
Wie alt ist es denn geworden?
75.
75? Ich dachte für 70 in Uhr.
Ja, rechnen wir mal nach.
140 in 1909, so haben wir wohl einen treuen Sinn.
Und ja, das wird ja auch, ich weiß nicht, da gibt es auch Feiern dazu.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist das alles sehr, wie soll ich sagen,
ein wichtiger Tag in der Demokratie.
Und das tolle Grundgesetz hat uns so viel gegeben und wir sind so froh,
dass wir es haben und deswegen machen wir heute eine Sendung zu dem Thema,
was ist, wenn das nicht mehr geht.
Das ist ja irre, genau, jetzt ist der passend zum Tag.
Deswegen, das siehst du mal, meine Assoziationskraft.
Steinmeier hat heute gesagt, das Grundgesetz ist ein Auftrag.
Und wir wissen, natürlich ist das nur ein Auftrag, weil die BRD ist ja auch nur eine GmbH.
Und deswegen ist das Grundgesetz quasi ein Auftrag an diese GmbH.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das Grundgesetz ist ja eher so ein Angebot.
Das aber bisher noch nicht abgenommen wurde, weil es sollte ja mal eine richtige
Verfassung gemacht werden, aber da hat man ja dann leider drauf verzichtet bei der Wende.
Naja, Steinmeier ist ein Bürokrat, der kennt halt Aufträge und die Aufträge
werden ausgeführt, insofern passt das eigentlich ganz gut zu uns.
Soll er mal machen.
Stimmen, ich höre Stimmen. Leute, wir haben Besuch heute, anlässlich des Geburtstages
des Grundgesetzes haben wir das Grundgesetz eingeladen.
Hallo, ich bin Grundi.
Genau, Grundi, also known as Arne, Arne Simmskreuz, herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Dankeschön, schön hier zu sein.
Genau, wir hatten dich ja auch schon mal da, aber nicht in der Meta-Ebene,
sondern on stage. Welches war das jetzt nochmal? 200, 100?
256.
Und Babylon, ja.
Das war sehr unterhaltsam.
Heute machen wir einen Gegenpult.
Das macht immer zu viel Spaß mit dir Heute machen wir mal.
Wir dachten eigentlich, es war so lustig Dann machen wir jetzt nochmal Ja,
nee, also ich meine Das ist definitiv Auf jeden Fall eine schöne Veranstaltung
Apropos Veranstaltung Linus?
Oh ja Wir haben ja so ein Datum 31.
August Mhm 2024 1900 hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt wegen 75 Jahren,
nein, aber 31. August 2024.
Das haben wir ja schon verkündet und haben euch schon ganz heiß gemacht auf
dieses Datum und jetzt lassen wir langsam den Vorhang hoch.
Ich habe schon Nachrichten bekommen, ich hätte gerne ein Ticket für die LNP 500. Tatsächlich.
Echt?
Ja, weil die Leute das gehört haben und dann haben die wahrscheinlich ihre Finger
genommen Wir haben gesagt.
Eigentlich müsste das Logbuch-Netzpolitik 512 sein, aber die faulen Säcke schaffen das bestimmt nicht.
Die legen sich im Sommer einfach auf die faule Haut, hängen die ganze Zeit auf
irgendwelchen Festivals rum.
Tatsächlich war sogar die Nachricht LMP 500 oder 512 oder was auch immer ihr davor habt.
Aber wir haben dann auf 500 gedowngradet.
Ja, mehr trauen wir uns nicht zu. Bis dahin.
Genau, also das werden wir tun. In Berlin. Genau, in Berlin.
Wir laden euch alle ein. Bald. Bald.
Wir laden euch bald alle ein. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen so ein Teaser dafür.
Und ja, das Ganze wird in Berlin stattfinden. Mit anderen Worten,
wir haben einen Ort gefunden.
Das ist der Humboldtsaal in der Urania. Also in der City. In der City West.
In der Nähe des KDW. Kann man sehen, man ist in der Nähe der Stadion.
Ja, das ist gut, da könnt ihr vorher noch ein paar Geschenke einbringen.
Könnt ihr noch ein bisschen Geld in der insolventen Bude lassen.
Gibt es das noch? Gibt es das KDW noch?
Das KDW gibt es noch.
Klar.
Das geht da noch?
Das wird auch immer bleiben.
Gehst du da nicht sonntags morgens immer aus deinem Essen und so?
Du bringst mich auf gute Ideen. Ich habe Sonntag noch nichts vor.
Ja, KDW gibt es, glaube ich, noch.
Ja, das wird es auch immer geben, weil die Reichen werden sich ja ihr Kaufhaus nicht nehmen lassen.
Naja, also dem Benko gehört es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht mehr.
Gehört das dem Benko?
Ich glaube, das war auch von dieser Benko. Gab es irgendwo ein Kaufhaus, was nicht dem Ja.
Das gehört glaube ich dem Insolvenzverwalter.
Luxuskaufhaus KDW. Besitzer René Benko verkauft Mehrheit. Ne,
gehört dem nicht mehr. Der verkauft.
Okay.
Können wir leider nicht in die Shownotes nehmen. Das ist ein Axel Springer Link.
Naja, auf jeden Fall Gehört einer italienischen Kaufhauskette Okay Naja, passt doch Oh.
2015 schon verkauft Na gut.
Wir werden auf jeden Fall euch dann einladen und auch nochmal Bescheid sagen
wenn es die Tickets gibt dafür, das bedarf noch der ein oder anderen,
Vorbereitung und dann freuen wir uns natürlich vor allem, wenn ihr dabei seid
Wir werden, wie immer, interessante Interessante Gäste dort haben.
Und mehr gibt es erstmal nicht zu erzählen, oder?
Bald gibt es dann Tickets.
Machen wir dann die 512 eigentlich auch noch was Tolles?
Das ist eine Ahne-Frage.
Wir sehen uns im KDW dann.
Austern schlürfen mit Lockbuch-Netzpolitik.
Der ist mir zu salzig. Gut, jetzt zurück zum Grundgesetz.
Siegner hat das KDW an einen thailändischen Handelskonzern verkauft.
Ist die letzte Nachricht, die ich dazu finde. Aber nochmal, also es ist nicht
im KDW, weil wir jetzt den Link, den einzigen Link zu dem Thema in den Showrooms ist KDW.
Die sitzen dann alle in der fünften Etage und schlürfen aus dann und wir so, wo sind die Gäste?
Ja.
Arne, du hast ein Buch geschrieben. Können wir darüber reden, wie du das gemacht hast?
Ja,
Ähm, ich bin weggefahren.
Du hast dich einen Monat auf einer fernen Insel, deutsche Insel eigentlich,
eine deutsche Insel vor Spanien, hast dich da einen Monat einquartiert und hast ein Buch geschrieben.
Ich glaube, das ist etwas, also Menschen, die Bücher schreiben,
wissen, das dauert eigentlich viele Jahre.
Man hat mehrere Phasen der Verzweiflung, der Frustration.
Was ist das Geheimnis, dass du das geschafft hast?
Ich habe diese Frustration, die Verzweiflung sehr intensiv in sehr kurzer Zeit einfach durchlebt.
Also tatsächlich angefangen mit dem Buchschreiben habe ich so im November letzten Jahres.
Das war als Reaktion auf ein Symposium mit Beamten tatsächlich.
Das war das produktivste Symposium, auf dem ich je war.
Das halte ich jetzt für einen Scherz. Nee, nee, tatsächlich nicht,
weil sich im Anschluss an dieses Symposium, da standen wir danach noch so ein
bisschen rum, ganz viele Beamte darüber unterhalten haben, was sie machen würden,
wenn die AfD ihre Behörde übernimmt.
Und das fand ich wahnsinnig interessant, weil mir das nicht klar war,
dass das in der Beamtenschaft eine riesige Frage ist gerade.
Also ich meine, wir haben in Deutschland fünf Millionen Beamten und die haben
sich da bei diesem Symposium alle gefragt,
wenn ich jetzt in dieser Behörde bin und der Behördenchef kommt jetzt von der
AfD, soll ich bleiben und das Ganze verzögern, was der da vorhat?
Soll ich gehen, aber dann wird das nachbesetzt.
Also should I stay or should I go, haben die sich alle gefragt.
Und das fand ich so wahnsinnig interessant. Und niemand hatte eine Antwort darauf.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, dem gehe ich mal nach.
Bin auf Verlage zugegangen, da gab es ein paar Interessenten.
Und dann wollte ich das bis Ende dieses Jahres schreiben.
Und dann hat der Verlag gesagt, nee, das machen wir mal ein halbes Jahr schneller. Da habe ich gesagt ...
Oh oh. Und habe dann aber zugesagt, weil das natürlich jetzt ein Riesenthema
ist und noch größer werden wird mit den ganzen Wahlen, die jetzt anstehen.
Also im Juni ist Europawahl, aber auch Kommunalwahl in vielen Bundesländern.
Dann haben wir im September die Landtagswahlen in Sachsen, Brandenburg und in
Thüringen. Da wird auch noch einiges auf uns zukommen.
Das heißt, das ist sowieso aktuell und dann bin ich so ein bisschen in Turbo-Modus
gegangen und habe ein Buch geschrieben, das versucht, die Frage zu beantworten.
Should I stay or should I go?
Dafür musst du ja eine, also du musst dafür,
man braucht wahrscheinlich eine echt gute Kenntnis der unterschiedlichen Behörden,
also auf Länderebene, auf Bundesebene und wie die jeweils welche Einflussmöglichkeiten
die haben und wie man deren Einflussmöglichkeiten verändern kann.
Das ist doch schon ein ziemlich komplexes Gebilde.
Hattest du dieses ganze Wissen einfach schon durch deine Arbeit an Frag den Staat?
Genau, also das ist auf jeden Fall der Teil im Buch, der mir am ehesten zugeflogen
ist, würde ich sagen, weil wir im Prinzip tagtäglich genau das machen, nämlich zu schauen,
wie funktionieren denn eigentlich Entscheidungsprozesse und wir versuchen ja
Akten darüber zu bekommen bei Frag den Staat, das heißt wir kämpfen eh darum
rauszufinden, wie das denn eigentlich funktioniert.
Wer welche Einflussmöglichkeiten hat und dementsprechend ist dann aus so verschiedenen
Prozessen auch ganz gut klar, wie funktioniert das denn, wenn Beamte keinen Bock haben.
Das sieht man doch jeden Tag.
Genau, aber das ist dann ja auch eine interessante Frage der Sabotage gegenüber
der AfD. Was ist denn, wenn die Leute keinen Bock haben, das umzusetzen?
Und von dieser Frage geht es so ein bisschen aus in dem Buch und dann geht es
so auf verschiedene gesellschaftliche Bereiche, also was die so alle machen können.
Das Buch heißt Machtübernahme. Was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremisten regieren?
Eine Anleitung zum Widerstand.
Also es ist sozusagen nicht nur ein Buch, sondern es ist eigentlich auch eine
Anleitung zum Handeln, wenn ich das richtig deute.
Der Verlag ist der Drömer, heißt der nicht Drömer?
Drömer heißt er, ja.
Ist der nicht mal Drömer-Knauer oder so?
So heißt er auch.
So heißt er auch?
Also am Schluss gehört es alles einem Milliardär. Das ist ja das Schöne,
so Rowold, Fischer, Drömer, Knauer, am Schluss alles Holzbrink.
Alles der gleiche Milliardär. Echt?
Wow. Also können wir auch eigentlich sagen Holzbrink erscheint beim Milliardär Holzbrink.
Okay, das ist ja eine gute Gesellschaft. Gut, und das ist auch schon verfügbar?
Das ist im Handel ab dem 3.6. und jetzt allmählich wird es glaube ich schon
ein bisschen vorher ausgeliefert.
Wäre sinnvoll, man kann es jetzt schon vorbestellen. Ich habe das schon vor
sehr vielen Monaten vorbestellt.
Als du bekannt gegeben hast, dass du ein Buch geschrieben hast und das erscheinen
wird, da dachte ich, hat der doch noch gar nicht geschrieben so lange.
Das kann doch noch niemals fertig sein. Aber warst du tatsächlich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon?
Ja, so halb genau. Aber es ist wirklich verrückt in solchen Prozessen.
Da muss man dann den Klappentext quasi schreiben, häufig bevor man das Buch
geschrieben hat und dann schreibt man diesen Klappentext hinterher.
Natürlich schreibt man das wichtigste zuerst. Das wird ja von den meisten gelesen.
Also du hast eine Kenntnis dessen, wie das alles funktioniert und jetzt sagst du, okay, welche,
Einflussmöglichkeiten die gewinnen, hast du nicht auch Sorge,
dass die das jetzt lesen und sagen, geil, da steht drin, was passiert,
wenn wir an die Macht kommen?
Weil ich glaube Ich glaube nicht, dass die das... Naja, es könnte ja auch sein,
dass die keinen Plan haben.
Schön wär's, ja. Aber haben sie leider.
Also wenn man sich so ein paar Videos anschaut von Höcke zum Beispiel und sich
anschaut, wie der beschreibt, was die in so einem Fall der Machtübernahme machen
würden, dann ist das ziemlich konkret.
Also die rechnen zum Beispiel aus, wie sie in Thüringen in den Behörden,
wie viele Personen sie direkt auswechseln könnten.
Also es gibt so eine Unterscheidung im Beamtentum zwischen den politischen Beamten,
das sind dann in der Regel so Staatssekretären zum Beispiel oder auch Chefs
vom Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Das sind politische Beamtinnen,
die kann man direkt austauschen.
Das heißt, wenn ein, machen wir es mal ein bisschen neutraler,
ein Nancy Faeser Ministerium übernimmt, dann kann die direkt erstmal diese Chefpositionen austauschen.
Hat sie aber nicht gemacht.
Interessanterweise nicht, genau. Die hat wahnsinnig viel übernommen von Seehofer,
was glaube ich auch erklärt, warum der Kurs dieses Hauses ähnlich ist.
Ich würde ja tippen, ein AfD-Innenminister würde ein paar der Leute auch beibehalten,
aber das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Spekulation.
Aber die überlegen sich jetzt schon, wen können sie denn direkt austauschen.
Also bei anderen Beamtinnen, so auf niedrigerer Ebene ist es schwieriger unter
dem jetzigen Beamtenrecht, die haben ganz viel Kündigungsschutz und so weiter und so weiter.
Aber so Schlüsselstellen in diesem hierarchisch strukturierten Betrieb,
die kann man direkt austauschen. Das schauen die sich alles zum Beispiel an.
Das heißt, die Planungen, die sind schon sehr konkret und ich würde davon ausgehen,
für die ist das jetzt nichts Neues.
Schauen wir doch mal so ein bisschen auf die aktuelle Realität,
wo eigentlich die AfD, und reden wir jetzt eigentlich nur über die AfD? Schon eigentlich.
Also wir können auch neutraler von autoritär-populistischen Parteien reden,
aber ich glaube, also konkret ist die Gefahr bei der AfD da. Okay.
Was für einen Einfluss hat denn die AfD schon heute und wo zeigt sich sozusagen
das, was wir im größeren Stil vermuten, in Ansätzen vielleicht auch schon?
Ja, wenn wir uns die verschiedenen Gewalten anschauen, also die Judikative,
die Legislative, die Exekutive, dann gibt es in all diesen Bereichen jetzt schon
Einflussmöglichkeiten für die AfD.
Legislative, das sind die Parlamente, eigentlich relativ klar.
Die AfD hat dadurch, dass sie in den Landtagen, im Bundestag sitzt,
schon jetzt parlamentarische Informationsrechte.
Also die können zum Beispiel in vielen Landtagen Untersuchungsausschüsse einberufen
und darüber haben sie die Möglichkeit sehr umfassend, das kennen wir ja aus
Untersuchungsausschüssen zu NSU oder NSA oder so,
die können eine ganze Menge Informationen anfordern. Das kann die AfD auch machen.
Und wir wissen ja, die AfD hat sehr gute Verbindungen in auch die gewaltbereite rechte Szene.
Das heißt, was da AfD-Politiker an Infos bekommen.
Kann man sich vorstellen, wird dann auch gut weitergeleitet.
Und wenn es dann zum Beispiel Untersuchungsausschüsse gibt,
die dann auch Informationen in Bezug auf Demokratieinitiativen,
vielleicht Initiativen in Asyl- und Migrationsberatung und so anfordern,
dann hat die AfD jetzt schon Möglichkeit,
auch sehr sensible Daten zu sammeln.
Und das wissen tatsächlich viele Initiativen in dem Bereich gar nicht unbedingt.
Andere wissen das sehr gut, dass wenn die eine staatliche Förderung bekommen,
Und darüber dann Infos an Behörden geben.
Diese Behörden das wiederum häufig weitergeben müssen an die Parlamente.
Das ist ja auch an sich erstmal richtig, dass die Behörden, also die Exekutive
kontrolliert wird vom Parlament.
Und das wollen wir auch eigentlich gar nicht ändern. Aber dadurch,
dass die AfD dann diese Möglichkeiten hat,
ist das jetzt unter Datenschutzgesichtspunkten schon auch ein Problem,
dass sie darüber Infos bekommen kann und damit dann natürlich weiter Arbeit
machen kann, das skandalisieren kann, möglicherweise Leute bedrohen kann.
Das ist so dieser Strang der Legislative.
Und die AfD hat darüber dann jetzt schon so ein bisschen Zugriff auf Gremien.
Also es gibt so häufig Beiräte zum Beispiel, in denen die drin sitzen.
Also Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung zum Beispiel, da sitzt die AfD mit drin.
Aber es gibt auf kommunaler Ebene oder auf Landesebene dann auch Beiräte von
öffentlichen Unternehmen zum Beispiel, wo dann die AfD mit drin sitzt.
Oder Vertreter der AfD mit drin sitzen.
Was meinst du mit öffentlichen Unternehmen?
Also zum Beispiel, genau, ja, sowas. Also die sind dann in öffentlicher Hand
und die AfD sitzt dann da einfach mit drin.
Und die AfD hat ja inzwischen, und das wird jetzt einfach zunehmen, Wahlerfolge.
Also Landratsämter, die die dann übernehmen können,
über Gemeinde, Stadträte, bestimmte Einflussmöglichkeiten, wo sie dann möglicherweise
Mehrheiten bekommen und da dann ganz einfach Einflussmöglichkeiten haben.
Und das kommt dann immer auf die Ebene an.
Aber gerade wenn es dann um so Entscheidungen geht wie, wo setzen wir hier das
Heim für Asylsuchende hin oder so, so hier rein in die Stadt oder irgendwo ganz weit draußen,
dann haben die bei sowas zum Beispiel ein Mitspracherecht auf kommunaler Ebene.
Und dann haben wir noch diesen Bereich der Judikative und AfD-RichterInnen.
Und da gibt es ja immer mal wieder Fälle von rechten Richtern, die bekannt werden,
wo dann zum Beispiel gegen, oder auch Staatsanwälten oder so,
wo dann auf einmal gegen das Zentrum für politische Schönheit ermittelt wird.
Und dann kommt am Schluss raus, hey, dieser Staatsanwalt, der die Ermittlungen
vorangetrieben hat, der hat gleichzeitig der AfD gespendet.
Also wenn wir Umfragewerte von 20, 30 Prozent für die AfD haben,
dann ist das natürlich überall so.
Also dann ist das auch in der Richter- und Staatsanwaltschaft so,
dann ist das auch in der Beamtenschaft so.
Da sind dann natürlich auch Vertreter. Die sieht man dann vielleicht nicht direkt,
aber das macht sich dann schon bemerkbar über die Zeit.
Jetzt wäre ja aber, eigentlich hätte ich jetzt so gedacht,
diese demokratische Struktur, die wurde ja von Profis geschaffen,
viele gegenseitige Checks and Balances, die da drin sind,
die ja, das was auch häufig mal ärgerlich ist, aber die natürlich im Prinzip
dafür da sind, dass Systeme, dass dieses System sich stabilisiert und gegen
Veränderungen ja, sich mit einer gewissen Trägheit,
wendet. Ähm,
Du sagst aber, also klar, die gewinnen dann natürlich Möglichkeiten,
man möchte vielleicht lieber nicht von, also je nachdem, wer man ist,
möchte man einen AfD-Richter haben oder nicht.
Aber dieses Richterbeispiel, wie du schon sagst, die waren ja schon immer da,
die waren wahrscheinlich potenziell, vielleicht ist da sogar eher ein konservatives
Spektrum bei den Richterinnen vertreten als ein progressives.
Ist.
Trotzdem hatte man ja jetzt in der Regel noch grob konnte man darauf vertrauen,
dass man vor Gericht ungefähr so sicher ist wie auf hoher See.
Leute wie du und ich zumindest, ja. Das ist glaube ich auch für den Bereich am ehesten richtig.
Also ich würde auch sagen, die Justiz, die ist behäbig, bis es weh tut.
Und das hat natürlich auch was Gutes. Das heißt eben, dass Veränderungen in
alle Richtungen wahnsinnig schwer sind und eben auch zum Schlechteren.
Also zum Beispiel sowas wie die Richterwahl über Richterwahlausschüsse,
das ist schon sehr kompliziert und ganz schön fern von der Exekutive.
Also ein Justizministerium kann jetzt nicht einfach so mal alle Richter austauschen zum Beispiel.
Und das hat sicher ganz viel Gutes.
Es gibt halt andere Bereiche, da geht sowas viel schneller.
Also über diese Besetzung der politischen Beamten hatte ich schon gesprochen.
Wenn halt ein AfD es mal schafft, eine Behördenleitung zu übernehmen.
Oder Vertreter von der AfD.
Und das Gleiche gilt natürlich bei den Parlamenten. Wenn die dann irgendwie
eine Sperrminorität haben und bestimmte Prozesse blockieren können oder tatsächlich
eine Mehrheit haben, dann geht es in sowas deutlich schneller.
Was du, glaube ich, noch nicht angesprochen hast, ist ja auch die Gründung von
Stiftungen. Also diese, wie heißt sie noch?
Desiderius Erasmus.
Ja, Desiderius Erasmus.
Genau, Stiftung mit dieser Stiftung.
Ist das immer noch dieselbe Vorsitzende?
Erika Steinbach.
Das ist ja auch so ein Fossil. Seit ich Politik begleite, und das ist ja leider schon eine Weile.
Ist das eine alte, schlecht gelaunte Frau?
Genau, sie war schon immer eine alte, schlecht gelaunte Frau.
Sie wird dich auch überleben, Tim. Egal wie lange du noch Politik machst.
Gott.
Das klingt jetzt nicht so hoffnungsvoll.
Genau, die parteinahe Stiftung der AfD.
Ja, die Parteienstiftung der AfD, angeführt von Erika Steinbach,
die halt früher der rechtskonservative Flügel der CDU war, fast schon in Alleinvertretung,
hat man manchmal so den Eindruck gehabt.
Natürlich gab es, CDU ist ja eine Sammlungsbewegung und damals ist es ja quasi
der CDU auch noch gelungen, diesen rechten Rand in irgendeiner Form im Griff zu halten.
Natürlich konnte sie dort weniger Schaden anrichten, als sie es eben jetzt tut.
Aber es geht ja nicht um Erika Steinbach.
Nur ein weiteres Beispiel, wo die AfD heute auch schon ist und darüber ja dann
eben auch Gelder vom Staat einsammelt, die sich an diesen Stiftungen beteiligen.
Und ja, das ist halt auch so.
Kriegen können, aber weil jetzt aus diesem Anlass der Bundestag endlich ein
Stiftungsfinanzierungsgesetz letztes Jahr noch verabschiedet hat,
haben die erstmal keinen Zugriff auf diese Gelder.
Also das ist eigentlich ein erfolgreiches Modell, wie man es endlich schaffen
kann, die von so einer Finanzierung abzuschneiden, weil natürlich in allen anderen
Bereichen die AfD finanziell boomt.
Tatsächlich auch durch Boomer, ganz interessant, weil die natürlich total viel spenden,
also die AfD halt wirklich in Geld schwimmt derzeit und in absehbarer Zeit auch
noch viel mehr Geld bekommen wird, unter anderem durchs Erben.
Also es gibt jetzt so eine Generation, die allmählich stirbt,
die dann echt viel Geld an die AfD vererben wird und das Geld wird denen erstmal
nicht ausgehen und deswegen ist glaube ich so eine Frage von wie kann man denen
den Geldhahn abdrehen eigentlich auch total zentral.
Da kommt dann diese Partei, wie heißt diese Partei für das Ende des Todes,
Partei für ewiges Leben durch Forschung.
Gesundheitsforschung.
Das wäre jetzt Gesundheitsforschung. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich deren Wahlspot
ist, den ich da gesehen habe, aber ein äußerst verstörendes Internetvideo,
wo sie offenbar ihre Frustration über den Tod zum Ausdruck bringen möchten und
den dann deswegen gewaltsam töten.
Ich habe gerade mal dieses Gesetz zur Finanzierung politischer Stiftung aus
dem Bundeshaushalt kurz nachgeschlagen.
Im Bundestagszusammenfasser übrigens.
Und gesehen, Eingang im Bundestag 9.10.2023 und die finale Version war dann
schon Ausfertigungsdatum 19.12.
Und die Abstimmung war schon im November. Also es hat gerade mal einen Monat
gedauert von erster Vorlage bis Abstimmung.
Das ist schnell durchgeprügelt worden, ja. Was man da nicht sehen kann,
sind die Jahre davor, die wir und andere appelliert haben und appelliert und
appelliert, dass wirklich was passiert und die haben sich ewig Zeit gelassen.
Und dann am Schluss ging es aber tatsächlich schnell, weil es da nämlich um
den nächsten Bundeshaushalt ging.
Also da ging es dann um die Frage, kriegt die AfD-Nahstiftung nächstes Mal Geld?
Und die standen in den Startlöchern und
dann muss man schnell noch vor dem Bundeshaushalt dieses Gesetz machen.
Wie, also vielleicht machen wir ganz kurz den Exkurs, wie funktioniert dieses
Parteistiftungsfinanzierungsgesetz?
Also einmal, warum haben Parteien Stiftungen?
Also üblicherweise hat man die zum Steuern sparen, siehe letzte Logbuch in Netzpolitik,
wo wir uns um Steuervermeidungsmodelle und Gemeinnützigkeit aufgeschlaut haben.
Und diese Stiftungen sind auch gemeinnützig?
Oder streben eine solche Gemeinnützigkeit an?
Sind sie in der Regel, ja. Also es sind eigentlich alles, also rein rechtlich
sind es glaube ich alles, bis auf die Friedrich-Naumann-Stiftung von der FDP,
Vereine, gemeinnützige Vereine, die den politischen Bildungsauftrag,
also einen Auftrag der politischen Willensbildung im Umfeld der Parteien wahrnehmen.
Das ist so ein deutsches Spezifikum. Ich glaube, solche Stiftungen gibt es eigentlich
in anderen Ländern, in anderen Staaten gar nicht so.
Das hat sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten aber in Deutschland so gebildet und
ist auch allgemein als gut anerkannt worden.
Also man kennt ja diese Stiftungen eigentlich, die laufen überall rum.
Das ist von links bis rechts so Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung, Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung,
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung, Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, Friedrich-Naumann-Stiftung,
Hans-Seidel-Stiftung von der CSU.
Die haben viele Jahrzehnte ohne gesetzliche Grundlage hunderte Millionen Euro bekommen.
Das wurde einfach so im Haushaltsgesetz immer reingeschrieben und dann haben
die damit Bildungsarbeit gemacht und haben so teilweise so ein bisschen Think
Tank artig im Umfeld der Parteien vorgedacht oder zurückgedacht,
je nach politischer Couleur.
Da gab es ein riesen Transparenzproblem. Da wurde auch jahrzehntelang gefordert,
dass man hier einfach so hunderte Millionen an Parteien und parteinahen Stiftungen geben kann.
Wurde aber nie was mitgemacht, weil alle sich darauf eingerichtet hatten.
Also die Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung oder die Linken, die hatten immer ein Problem
mit diesem System und dann wurde ihre Stiftung auch finanziert und dann hatten
sie irgendwie kein Problem mehr damit.
Und jetzt aus Anlass dieser AfD-Nahen Stiftung haben sie sich aber endlich dazu
durchgerungen, so ein Gesetz zu machen, das letztlich ein bisschen Rahmen vorgibt.
Nämlich sagt, unter welchen Umständen man Recht hat auf Finanzierung.
Und da steht dann eben unter anderem drin, dass man eine gewisse Anzahl von
Legislaturperioden im Parlament sein muss.
Und siehe da, die AfD ist noch nicht oft genug im Parlament gewesen und allein
deswegen haben sie kein Anrecht auf Förderung.
Und dazu dann aber auch, dass bestimmte Kriterien erfüllt werden müssen,
die letztlich so Gemeinnützigkeitskriterien entsprechen.
Und ich würde davon ausgehen, dass die AfD-nahe Stiftung die dann auch nicht erfüllt.
Also selbst wenn sie wieder reinkommen in den Bundestag und dann rein formell
drunter fallen würden unter so einem Gleichheitsgrundsatz, eine Fördermöglichkeit,
würde ich davon ausgehen, dass eine Prüfung dann ergibt,
dass die letztlich auch nicht förderwürdig sind.
Kannst du sagen, an was für einem Kriterium ungefähr die dann scheitern würden?
Ja, wir haben tatsächlich so ein bisschen auch im Gesetzgebungsprozess so von
der Seitenlinie beraten.
Weil wir uns in den letzten Jahren deren die Materialien und die Personen im
Umfeld dieser Stiftung angeschaut hatten von Fragtenstaatseite,
wo halt enorm viele Leute aus der Extremrechten, der neuen Rechten,
also der antidemokratischen Rechten versammelt sind.
Und wenn man dann so Schriften von denen analysiert, dann kann man gut zum Schluss
kommen, dass viele der Inhalte rassistisch sind,
dass die queerfeindlich sind, dass die in verschiedener Form menschenfeindlich sind.
Und in diesem Gesetz steht jetzt drin,
dass kein Anspruch auf Förderung besteht, wenn so zentrale Veröffentlichungen
dieser Stiftung die Erwartung begründen, dass die Stiftungsarbeit nicht im Sinne
der Völkerverständigung ist.
Also das ist so ein bisschen natürlich verklausuliert, aber ganz grob,
wenn die halt menschenfeindliche Arbeit machen, dann sollen sie nicht noch zusätzlich
staatliches Geld dafür bekommen.
Und das kann man eigentlich an vielen Publikationen von dieser Stiftung sehen.
Also egal zu was die schreiben, am Schluss enden die in irgendeinem rassistischen Scheiß.
Steht da jetzt nur drin Völkerverständigung? Weil ich kenne ja diese gesamte
also eine ähnliche Debatte wurde,
wenn ich mich recht entsinne, von rechter Seite um politische Initiativen geführt im,
liberalen linken Spektrum wo dann quasi, was war das?
Die mussten sich alle zur freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung bekennen.
Genau, das steht drin, die FDGO. Ja, und das ist tatsächlich...
Das ist natürlich auch etwas, was passieren könnte.
Also unter einer anderen Regierung oder in einer anderen politischen Konstellation
könnte man so ein Gesetz natürlich auch nehmen und sagen,
huch, was die Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung da macht, ist das denn eigentlich noch
gedeckt von der freiheitlichen demokratischen Grundordnung?
Und dann fragen, was ist denn das mit der FTGO, wer schreibt denn darüber?
Ah, das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz schreibt darüber, wir schauen mal in
den Verfassungsschutzbericht und dann schauen wir uns an, mit wem denn die Stiftungen
so kooperieren und die IL,
interventionistische Linke, die ist doch bei Deutsche Wohnen in Alten dabei
und die sind doch eigentlich mit der Stiftung und so weiter.
Also so ein Potenzial, das in verschiedene Richtungen in Stellung zu bringen, ist auf jeden Fall da.
Und das war auch eine große Diskussion im Umfeld dieses Stiftungsfinanzierungsgesetzes,
wie man das denn formuliert,
weil sich eigentlich alle einig sind, dass das Problem die Desiderius Erasmus
Stiftung ist und jetzt keine andere Stiftung in dem Bereich.
Heinrich Böll Stiftung.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass die Ich.
Würde aber trotzdem verlangen, dass sie sich mal hier den Gerüchten entgegentreten,
dass sie die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung ablehnen Herr Fuchs Was okay.
Jetzt, das ist so ein bisschen die Ist-Situation und was siehst du denn,
was jetzt droht, dass dich dazu bringt, sogar ein Buch zu schreiben Ja.
Also die Grundsituation, mit der ich reingegangen bin und die ich so interessant
und beängstigend finde, ist quasi der Wahlabend.
Also wir haben einen Wahlabend und die AfD kriegt irgendwie eine Mehrheit oder
kriegt so viele Stimmen, dass eine Koalition mit ihnen denkbar ist.
Und die Frage, was passiert in diesem Moment? Ähm, und...
Ich glaube, was es so an Szenarien in den letzten Monaten viel in den Medien
gab, war, die AfD kommt an die Macht und die Demokratie wird abgeschafft. Fertig, so.
Da haben wir die Massendeportation und dann war es das mit uns. So wie 1933.
Also ein bisschen zugespitzt, aber das ist ja so ein bisschen das Szenario.
Und meine Vermutung wäre, dass das nicht ist, wie es passieren würde,
sondern dass es eher so eine Politik mit Schritt für Schritt gibt.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es in einigen Ostbundesländern,
wo es einen komischen CDU-Landesverband gibt, durchaus eine CDU-AfD-Koalition geben könnte.
Stellt euch so eine Konstellation vor, Koalitionen alle schwierig,
weil mit der Linkspartei will niemand koalieren und gleichzeitig irgendwie die
BSW mit drin von Sarah Wagenknecht, die ist irgendwie komisch und dann stellt
sich so ein CDU-Vorsitzender hin am Abend, am Wahlabend und sagt,
wir nehmen unsere staatspolitische Verantwortung wahr.
Den Wählerwillen, wir wurden ja schließlich gewählt hier von.
Und außerdem, wir müssen verhindern, dass es hier Chaos gibt.
Wir machen jetzt eine stabile Koalition, aber wir werden darauf achten,
dass die AfD entzaubert wird.
Und wir stellen dem Ministerpräsidenten, wir machen das schon.
Und dann hätten wir eine Situation, wo die AfD Zugriff bekommt auf einzelne
Ministerien. Und dann könnte vielleicht eine CDU sagen, ja, aber wir lassen
die jetzt nicht viel über neue Gesetze mitbestimmen, wir halten die klein.
Also wir machen jetzt nicht viele Gesetze mit denen zusammen,
wir bringen unsere eigenen Gesetze durch, wir lassen denen nur diese paar Ministerien.
Und allein in so einer Situation hätte ein AfD-Minister schon die Möglichkeit,
allein nur innerhalb von einem Ministerium wahnsinnig viel zu machen.
Weil es zum einen total viele Gesetze gibt, die….
Einen enormen Spielraum lassen. Da können wir ja gleich ein bisschen drüber
reden, was so netzpolitisch in den letzten Jahren verabschiedet wurde und wie
das ausgefüllt werden kann und nochmal anders ausgefüllt werden kann als bisher.
Und man kann natürlich auch Erlasse und Verordnung machen. Also man ist gar
nicht als Minister darauf angewiesen in vielen Bereichen ein Gesetz durchs Parlament
zu bringen, sondern es gibt so Exekutivrechte, die gehen ganz schön weit.
Also eine Polizei anweisen und neue Erlasse für den Einsatz von bestimmten Waffen machen und so.
Da brauche ich in vielen Fällen gar kein Gesetz für, sondern ich habe eine Ermächtigungsgrundlage
im Gesetz, um das zu machen.
Das heißt, es gibt schon so eine enorme Machtfülle, gerade im Innenministerium,
ob Land oder Bund, mit dem man total viel machen kann.
Und deswegen wäre auch eine AfD in so einer Koalition, wo man dann sagt,
Juniorpartner, so viel können die gar nicht machen, selbst da total mächtig.
Und das ist so die Konstellation, mit der ich mich viel beschäftigt habe und
die ich so gefährlich finde, weil dann vielleicht auch nach außen gesagt werden würde,
jetzt aber so schlimm wie erwartet sind die ja gar nicht.
Die haben jetzt ja gar nicht diese Massendeportation von Millionen von Menschen
gemacht, sondern die haben hier nur Abschiebungen nach Syrien gemacht,
aber das ist jetzt ja eh mal Zeit und das waren jetzt auch nicht so viele.
Und hey, die haben jetzt irgendwie präventiv gewahrsam auch gemacht für diese
komischen linken Leute vor dem AfD-Parteitag, aber das war ja eh Antifa,
das ist ja irgendwie komisch. und präventiv gewahrsam, das kennen wir ja auch
schon von der letzten Generation und so.
So schlimm ist das ja alles nicht. Und dann kämen wir in so eine Situation rein,
wo wir Schritt für Schritt letztlich in eine Situation kommen,
wo demokratische Rechte immer weiter ausgehöhlt werden.
Und das dann nicht mit einem Schlag, aber dann so ein Erosionsprozess.
Innenministerium, klar, da Primärpolizei-Tätigkeiten, also auch wo kontrolliert
wird, welche Statistiken sich am Ende aus der Polizei ergeben,
kann man natürlich sehr gut da lenken.
Wo man die Schwerpunkte setzt und dann natürlich auch entsprechend Dinge findet
und wie viele Polizisten und Polizistinnen sich dabei dann wieder einen Fingernagel
abbrechen und schwer verletzt.
Da kann man natürlich schon auch nicht nur erstens Dinge tun,
sondern natürlich auch sehr...
Sehr die Stimmung im Land lenken, wo Probleme wahrgenommen werden.
Genau. Und man hat einfach Zugriff auf enorm viele Menschen.
Also im Geschäftsbereich vom Bundesinnenministerium sind knapp 50.000 Leute.
Also das ist einfach wahnsinnig viel. Das ist dann die Bundespolizei zum Beispiel.
Auf Länderebene hast du die Landespolizeien. Also hast du in Deutschland 19
glaube ich verschiedene Polizeien, die natürlich alle auch eine unterschiedliche
Kultur haben und alle so ein bisschen anders funktionieren.
Aber auf die hast du dann Zugriff und dann kannst du natürlich sagen,
wo Razzien gemacht werden sollen und wo nicht.
Und wo man vielleicht ein bisschen verdachtsabhängige Kontrollen so macht und
was Indizien sind, die darauf hinweisen.
Und dann würde vielleicht in ein paar Jahren ein Gericht sagen,
das ist aber diskriminierend, diesen Anlass, den kannst du so nicht machen.
Aber bis dahin hat man es schon gemacht und dann formuliert man den halt neu
und versucht es nochmal.
Das ist ja im Prinzip das gleiche, was die CDU jetzt auch schon macht.
Genau, also tatsächlich muss man diese Mechanismen und wie sie funktionieren
gar nicht neu erfinden, sondern es geht eher darum, wie sie weiter gedreht und
extremisiert werden würden.
Dann hast du im Innenministerium natürlich, du hast den Zugriff auf die Geheimdienste,
also Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz beziehungsweise auf Bundesebene Bundesamt
für Verfassungsschutz.
Und wenn die jetzt gerade die AfD prüfen, dann könnten die natürlich unter einem
anderen Minister auch mal andere Parteien prüfen.
Und du hast gerade die Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung angesprochen und ich finde diese
Grünen, ja da könnte man auch nochmal schauen.
Also auch da hat man, glaube ich, große Zugriffsrechte und man hat natürlich
einfach Zugriffe auf Daten, auf enorme Datenmengen.
Also was ja leider, ich glaube ihr hattet das besprochen, aber sonst ziemlich
wenig besprochen wurde, ist dann das Ausländerzentralregister.
Also irgendwie die größte Datenbank, die Deutschland hat so ungefähr,
auf die inzwischen tausende Behörden Zugriff haben, wo AusländerInnen registriert
werden und ganz viele auch private Daten von denen und wo dann total viele Beamte
an verschiedenen Stellen Zugriff drauf haben.
Und das hast du dann als Exekutive, als Behördenleitung dann auch gleichzeitig
in deinem Geschäftsbereich.
Man darf glaube ich auch nicht unterschätzen, was so ein öffentliches Amt dann
auch an Medienabstrahlungsplus mit sich bringt.
Ich erinnere mich gerade noch an die Zeit vor etwas mehr als 20 Jahren,
als dieser Ronald Barnabas Schill in die Hamburger Landespolitik eingezogen
ist, auch durch so eine Protestwahl mit seiner Schill-Partei.
Und das war ja auch so ein kleiner Schnuller-Nazi, der irgendwie da gleich einen
dicken Max macht und dann ja auch Innensenator geworden ist und dann erstmal
irgendwie Harley Davidson für die Polizei gekauft hat und,
alle möglichen den haben wir übrigens auch zu verdanken, dass die Polizeiwagen
nicht mehr grün sind als blau.
Ne?
Ja, ja und dann kam halt so die, ja dann war irgendwie Flutkatastrophe im Osten,
und dann kann man dann halt gleich 11. September.
War 2001 war das.
Aber bei dieser Flutkatastrophe kann man dann irgendwie an mit so das ist alles,
weil wir zu viel Geld für Migranten ausgeben und so weiter, deswegen tun wir
nichts hier für Aber weißt du.
Wer der Vorgänger war von Ronald Barnabas Schill in Hamburg?
Puh, da testest du mich jetzt. Olaf Scholz Ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Es war Olaf Scholz und der war der war nur ein halbes Jahr oder so davor innen,
innen-Senator heißt das ja in Hamburg.
Und der kam da an die Macht, als die Schild-Partei bei 10% in den Umfragen war.
Und dann hat er sich gedacht, oh Gott, die von rechts, da müssen wir was machen,
wir machen jetzt Law and Order.
Und hat so ganz viele Law and Order-Maßnahmen durchgepeitscht,
unter anderem Brechmitteleinsatz, der dann zum Tod von einem Mann geführt hat.
Und hat damit total die Themen von Schill in den Mittelpunkt gerückt.
Und dann hat der Schill gesagt.
Guckt euch das an hier.
Genau. So ist der Weg und ich bin das Original, ich mach's richtig und am Schluss hat der 19% bekommen.
Also ein halbes Jahr Schill, nee, ein halbes Jahr Scholz als Innensenator,
Law and Order, hat einfach mal die Umfragewerte verdoppelt von dem Schill.
Und das finde ich als Mechanismus auch sehr interessant und Scholz ist danach
einfach weiter nach oben gefallen.
Klar, wo bin ich sonst?
Richter Gnadenlos.
Wo ein Inkompetenz so hinbringt. Richter Gnadenlos, so wurde er vorher genannt. Jaja, das ist so ein...
Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen durch die Landtagswahlen das potenzielle Szenario
einer Regierungsbeteiligung, zumindest erstmal auf Landesebene.
Ich glaube, da braucht man jetzt nicht viel Fantasie, um sich vorzustellen,
wie das jetzt in Sachsen und in Thüringen und vielleicht auch in Brandenburg dann aussehen wird,
weil es ist halt einfach zumindest damit zu rechnen oder man muss zumindest
davon ausgehen, dass es sein kann.
Ich will jetzt nichts hier herbeireden, dass der Stimmenanteil der AfD so groß
ist, dass sich so ohne weiteres keine Regierung an ihr vorbei bilden kann.
Das wäre natürlich schon irgendwie möglich, wenn die sich mal alle grün wären. Hö, hö, guter Witz.
Aber das ist ja auch schwierig. Und dann kommen ja schnell solche Argumente mit.
Man muss ja jetzt ja auch dem Volkswillen, dem Wählerwillen entsprechen und
was auch immer dann der Wählerwille ist.
Und das hätte dann wiederum auch eine Auswirkung auf den Bundesrat,
weil dann bestimmte Abstimmungen unter Umständen gar nicht mehr möglich sind,
bestimmte zustimmungspflichtige Gesetze, es gibt ja eine bestimmte Kategorie
von Gesetzen, da muss der Bundesrat zustimmen.
Die würden dann unter Umständen die Mehrheit nicht erreichen,
weil eine AfD in einer Koalition ja zumindest forcieren könnte,
dass man sich enthält und nicht zustimmt.
Genau, also was so Blockaden angeht, ist es jetzt gerade so,
dass die Union die Mehrheit hat im Bundesrat, also CDU und CSU und das sieht
man dann immer bei so zustimmungspflichtigen Gesetzen, Reform vom Bürgergeld
zum Beispiel, da reden die dann halt mit,
weil ohne die halt nichts geht und ähnliches wäre,
wenn die AfD in ausreichend vielen Regierungen beteiligt wäre,
dann für die auch möglich, genau.
Da stellt sich jetzt die Frage, wo haben wir denn so potenzielle Sollbruchstellen in unserem System?
Also wo siehst du Bereiche, wo es unter Umständen schnell schwierig werden könnte?
Also ich glaube, überall da haben wir jetzt schon ein Problem,
wo staatliche Befugnisse zu weit sind.
Also ich hatte den Eindruck, dass das, was wir…,
Was wir alle die ganze Zeit sagen, oh Gott, ihr dürft ihnen nicht diese Befugnisse geben.
Sonst wird es dann… Weil die zu hohes Missbrauchspotenzial haben.
Genau. Dass das jetzt nochmal konkreter wird und nochmal klarer wird,
was das denn eigentlich bedeutet.
Also dass irgendwie Befugnisse für die Polizei, bestimmte Überwachungsmaßnahmen zu machen,
das wird ja manchmal dann so ein bisschen als alarmistisch dargestellt,
wenn man sagt, Oh Gott, aber die werden das danach ausweiten und schaut mal,
was da theoretisch möglich ist.
Und dann wird gesagt, ja gut, aber in der Praxis ist es ja nochmal anders und
wir werden das ja mit Augenmaß machen und wir werden das ja nicht ganz ausreizen.
Und ich glaube, all diese Maßnahmen, die kann man sich dann anschauen und sagen,
ja okay, wenn man das aber wirklich konsequent ausfüllt, also jetzt auch beim
Asyl- und Migrationsrecht, wenn man konsequent die Abschiebemöglichkeiten nutzt,
dann kann man da viel mehr machen als jetzt schon.
Das heißt, das ist so eine erste Sollbruchstelle und muss man sagen, alles ungefähr.
Und eine zweite ist dann aber die Konstitution der Institutionen,
also die demokratische Verfasstheit von Institutionen.
Da wurde glaube ich in den letzten Monaten ein bisschen mehr darüber gesprochen,
wie zum Beispiel Einfluss auf
die Verfassungsgerichte auf Landes- und Bundesebene genommen werden kann,
die ja in vielen Fällen demokratische Rechte hochhalten und die dann auch ein
Hauptangriffspunkt wären für die AfD.
Genauso wie in Polen, Ungarn, wie in den USA unter Trump, auch das immer die Angriffspunkte waren.
Und so eine große Diskussion gab es jetzt um das Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz.
Also es ist so, dass ja die Richter in Wahl auf Bundesverfassungsgerichtsebene an sich erstmal.
Sehr stark darauf ausgerichtet ist, dass sie nicht einfach so von einer einfachen
Mehrheit geändert werden kann.
Also eine Richterinwahl ist über eine Zweidrittelwahl nur möglich des Bundestags.
Das heißt, da brauchst du eine Übereinkunft von demokratischen Parteien.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass das Gesetz, in dem drinsteht,
dass es nur mit einer Zweidrittelmehrheit möglich ist, mit einer einfachen Mehrheit geändert werden kann.
Das heißt, du hast an sich erstmal abgesichert, zwei Drittel, wunderbar,
so einfach kann man jetzt nicht so einen AfD-Kandidaten da reinkriegen,
aber dann würde natürlich eine AfD-Mehrheit, wenn es sie gäbe,
eben nicht darauf gehen, sondern die Rahmenbedingungen verändern,
sodass das nicht mehr notwendig ist und dann würden sie das ändern.
Und der große Vorschlag, den es jetzt gab in den letzten Monaten war,
dann eben auch dieses Verfahren in der Verfassung festzuhalten.
Also, dass es eine Zweidrittelmehrheit geben muss, auch im Grundgesetz festzuhalten.
Grundgesetz kann nur mit einer Zweidrittelmehrheit geändert werden und damit
hätte man da so einen stärkeren Rahmen. Und diese Diskussion gibt es so in verschiedenen Bereichen.
Und das halte ich auch für sinnvoll, weil das natürlich so eine Robustheit von
einem demokratischen System verstärkt.
Gleichzeitig auch immer mit der Gefahr, dass man das System noch behebiger macht.
Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt alles nur noch mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit irgendwann
ändern kannst, dann kann man halt auch Sachen nicht mehr einfach so zum Besseren verändern.
Also es hat immer auch eine schwierige Rückseite das Ganze.
Aber ich würde also so ganz grundsätzlich, wenn ich das jetzt in so einer Security-Sicht
sehe, würde ich so sagen, zwei Drittel Mehrheit ist vielleicht so der Second Factor.
Du kannst ja sagen, so Login und sowas alles machen wir einfach und zwei Drittel
machen wir da, wenn es irgendwie an die Substanz geht.
Alles jetzt auf zwei Drittel Mehrheit zu machen.
Wäre sicherlich Da würden wir komplett alles blockieren, dann können wir auch
nichts mehr verbessern, ja.
Aber dieses Beispiel, wenn man jetzt beim zweiten Faktor bleibt,
also so ungefähr, du hast du brauchst für alles einen zweiten Faktor,
nur nicht dafür, ihn abzuschalten, so, ne?
Das wäre also, erscheint mir dann wirklich ein Fehler zu sein,
also wirklich ein erkennbarer Security-Fehler.
Genau. Und das wurde jetzt...
Das wurde behoben?
Nee. Irgendwo gepostet wurde das. Ich versuche im Bild zu bleiben. Also das ist die...
Das hat einer auf Full Disclosure jetzt gedroppt.
Und die CDU unter Friedrich Merz weiß nicht, ob sie das jetzt machen wird oder nicht.
Und die wissen dann nicht, ob ihnen das wichtig genug ist. Die wissen nicht,
das müsste man halt als gemeinsame Sache machen mit der SPD und die wissen nicht,
ob sie das machen wollen und eiern da seit Monaten ganz furchtbar rum und deswegen
ist nicht klar, ob das jetzt wirklich kommt.
Ähm, man muss aber glaube ich auch grundsätzlich dazu sagen,
das sind alles wichtige Diskussionen und das ist auch notwendig,
da solche offensichtlichen Security-Probleme zu beheben,
aber am Ende kannst du jetzt nicht auf Dauer eine Demokratie gegen eine Mehrheit
durchsetzen, die die nicht mehr will, ne?
Also, wir sollten dann auch nicht mehr nur über Institutionen reden,
sondern es geht dann schon auch darum, dass wir Leute brauchen,
die diese demokratischen Institutionen gut finden.
Achso, oder man braucht Alliierte, das geht natürlich auch. Alliierte,
die sagen, ihr braucht jetzt eine Demokratie und ihr müsst das jetzt machen,
das ist theoretisch auch eine Möglichkeit.
Die haben ja für die letzten 60, 70 Jahre Ruhe geschaffen.
Ja, also der Alliierte Kontrollrat, vielleicht sollte man den auch zurückholen.
Naja, also es ist tatsächlich so,
dass das glaube ich notwendig ist und auch eine wichtige Voraussetzung,
aber gleichzeitig wir natürlich auch Leute brauchen,
die diese Institution mit Leben erfüllen und mit demokratischem Streit und das
ist dann am Ende noch wichtiger, würde ich sagen.
Das Verfassungsblock hat ja auch so eine ähnliche Fragestellung mal aufgerufen,
also diese Was-wäre-wenn-Frage für Thüringen, das Thüringen-Projekt,
hast du dir das auch genauer angeschaut?
Genau und mit denen sind wir auch rege im Austausch.
Die schauen sich das für das Bundesland Thüringen vor allem spezifisch an,
wo es denn überall diese Einfallstore gibt und dadurch, dass das Verfassungsblock
ein rechtswissenschaftliches Medium ist oder da zumindest der Block herkommt,
ist das dann in der Regel unter dem Gesichtspunkt, wie kann man denn bestehende
Gesetze so anpassen, dass sie robuster sind.
Also eine andere Frage ist dann zum Beispiel, wenn so ein Björn Höcke in Thüringen
sagt, er will den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk abschaffen, kann er das denn machen?
Was steht denn eigentlich drin im Medienstaatsvertrag? Und siehe da,
es braucht gar keine Zustimmung vom Parlament dazu, es kann der Ministerpräsident
einfach entscheiden, wir sind raus.
Und dann hast du so eine seltsame Konstellation von einem MDR.
Dann müssen wir wieder so einen Turm an die Mauer bauen oder was, um darüber zu streiten.
Ja, genau. Zumal der MDR ja weiter existieren würde. Der ist ja eine Mehrländerbehörde.
Aber dann auf einmal Thüringen dann vielleicht raus wäre aus dem MDR.
Und dann überlegst du, okay, was ist denn in Erfurt? Der Kinderkanal.
Der Kinderkanal wäre dann weg. Dann müsste man irgendwie den Kinderkanal woanders
aufbauen, ein paar Kilometer weiter dann irgendwie.
Also das sind dann halt Konstellationen, die sich dieses Thüringen-Projekt anschaut
und dann zum Beispiel vorschlägt, dass man sowas unter Parlamentsvorbehalt stecken müsste,
damit nicht mehr ein Ministerpräsident einfach so vom Medienstaatsvertrag zurücktreten kann.
Und davon gibt es natürlich unzählige Konstellationen, weil das auch so ein bisschen...
Einfach strifflig vernachlässigt wurde in den letzten Jahren,
sich eigentlich anzuschauen, wie verwundbar sind die Institutionen,
weil glaube ich viele Leute es so ein bisschen als selbstverständlich ansehen.
Also ich meine, ich eigentlich auch.
Ja, ich meine, hier drängt sich natürlich, so ein bisschen ist immer schwierig
mit dieser Nerd-Perspektive, aber hier drängt sich natürlich ein wenig so dieser
Vergleich mit Computersicherheit auf.
Wo ja auch die Dinge so ihren Lauf nehmen,
solange bis irgendwo mal gegengeklopft wird und dann stellt man auf einmal fest,
dass halt ein Black Hat, einer mit einem schwarzen Hut,
wenn der mal an der falschen Stelle klopft, dass dann Dinge auf einmal zusammenbrechen,
mit denen man so gar nicht gerechnet hat.
Und wo die Sicherheitsmechanismen eher so auf Goodwill und auf friedlicher Vereinbarung
und das haben wir doch immer schon so gemacht und das wollen doch auch alle
so auf dem Level irgendwie laufen.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist ja das,
was du jetzt mit dem Buch machst und auch was hier das Verfassungsblock gemacht
hat und was wir vielleicht auch alle in gewisser Hinsicht nochmal mehr tun sollten,
ist so eine Art Security-Scan auf Bundesrepublik,
um zu schauen, okay, wo sind denn jetzt hier vulnerable Bereiche,
die uns unter Umständen richtig viel Ärger machen können.
Ja, also ich glaube, der Vergleich trägt zumindest eine gewisse Weite schon, ja, aber,
Nee, ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt im Bild bleibe, dann wird das alles nur länger
lächeln. Aber das User-Interface.
Wie gesagt, ich will das auch gar nicht so sehr vertiefen.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt mal eine Awareness-Schulung machen.
Ja, ja, aber sagen wir mal so, so muss man ein bisschen mal drüber nachdenken.
Dass sehr viel in der Bundesrepublik der letzten 75 Jahre eben,
jetzt sind es genau 75 Jahre, viel auch bei Convention gelaufen ist.
Dass wir von bestimmten Dingen dann einfach annehmen, dass sie einfach da sind
und auch immer da bleiben, weil wer würde schon was anderes tun.
Aber wir es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße mit Personen zu tun haben,
die aus welcher Motivation auch immer bereit sind, diese Grundfesten schnell
mal durcheinander zu bringen.
Und wir haben das jetzt nun gerade mit der AfD, mit dem Herrn Krah zum Beispiel,
nicht der einzige und Brüstron,
wie er heißt, wo jetzt Zahlungen aus Russland publik geworden sind,
wo man auch merkt, es gibt halt auch einfach Leute, die bereit sind,
dieses Land einfach gegen Geld auszuliefern.
Weil die einfach zwar patriotisch tun, aber nicht wirklich patriotisch handeln.
So, jetzt ist ja dein Buch eine Anleitung So.
Und jetzt Bisher haben wir die Anleitung für die AfD, jetzt kommen wir mal Genau.
Jetzt wollen wir ja sozusagen die Anleitung, wie wir das alles verhindern können,
rette uns Arne Was hast du denn jetzt sozusagen ausgedacht in deinem einmonatigen,
Auszeit auf einer fernen Insel Scheiße.
Ich hätte es ahnen sollen Wenn ich ein Buch schreibe, dann sagen Leute, rette uns Arne Ja.
Klar Sag uns, was wir tun sollen, wir sind hilflos.
Er ist es, er ist es. Nein, ich bin es nicht. Nur der Matthias würde es sagen. Ähm...
Ich glaube, ich muss dazu sagen nochmal, wie schwer es mir fällt,
immer optimistisch und konstruktiv zu sein.
Das war dieser wunderschöne, wenn ich dich kurz unterbrechen darf,
mit einem Zitat von dir selber.
Bei dieser A New Hope Veranstaltung beim Kongress, wo du sinngemäß hattest,
nach jeder Niederlage denke ich, ich habe keine Hoffnung mehr und dann merke
ich nach der nächsten Niederlage, wie enttäuscht ich bin. Guck mal,
ich hatte doch noch Hoffnung. um.
Das fand ich alles anders.
Und irgendwie so, ja und ich bin ein bisschen überrascht, wie konstruktiv dieses
Buch geworden ist, sagen wir mal so.
Also weil ich trotzdem immer noch die ganze Zeit verzweifelt bin und denke,
da hilft dann überhaupt nichts und dann schaue ich mir aber an,
was so verschiedene Initiativen machen und was für tolle Ideen es gibt und irgendwie
für tolle Menschen und dann kriege ich doch wieder tatsächlich,
ja genau, halt doch diese Hoffnung.
Und Und es gibt in verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen total unterschiedliche
Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann.
Also jetzt in dem Buch unterteilt in Beamte erstmal, welche Möglichkeiten die haben.
Justiz, Unternehmen, Gewerkschaften, Zivilgesellschaften, natürlich Medien.
Was kann man in der CDU machen, wenn man in der CDU ist?
Also grundsätzlich glaube ich gilt für all diese Bereiche, dass es total sinnvoll
ist, sich überhaupt mit so einem Szenario zu beschäftigen und zwar unter der
Frage, was würde ich denn dann tun?
Also wir haben diese Wahlnacht und wir haben dann so eine Koalition oder die
AfD an der Macht, was würde ich an dieser Wahlnacht tun?
Überlegst du gerade schon?
Hast du das Haus auf der Insel gekauft oder?
Also auch das ist glaube ich ein Weg damit umzugehen.
Also was würde ich in dieser Situation tun und was würde ich danach tun?
Und ich finde das eigentlich einen ganz produktiven Gedanken,
weil ich zum Beispiel für diese Wahlnacht zu dem Schluss gekommen bin,
das mache ich jetzt auch für die Europawahl so, ich überlege mir vorher,
wem ich kurz Hallo sage in der Nacht.
Also ich überlege mir kurz vorher, für wen ist das wirklich schlimm,
wenn es so einen Rechtsruck gibt?
Also für mich natürlich, aber für manche Leute noch unmittelbarer.
Wem sage ich kurz in der Nacht, hey, ich denke an dich, das ist eine scheiß
Nacht, bevor ich dann heulend alleine ins Bett gehe, so ungefähr.
Also das ist so was sehr Kleines und dann….
Also es ist sehr klein, aber es zeigt natürlich auch, der erste wichtige Schritt
ist eben der der Solidarität, der hier ja dann sich darin ausdrückt.
Aber so, ey, scheiße für dich, ne?
Sorry.
Und daraus soll natürlich hoffentlich dann mehr entstehen, weil eine potenzielle
faschistische Gesellschaft eben natürlich sich gegen die Solidarität und den
Zusammenhalt und die Nächstenliebe.
Genau und wir ja spätestens im Januar diesen Jahres eigentlich bei diesen ganzen
Massenprotesten gesehen haben, dass es wahnsinnig viele Leute gibt,
die damit nicht einverstanden wären und die eigentlich für die Demokratie einstehen wollen,
aber vielleicht nicht genau wissen wie oder auch davon verzweifelt sind,
was gerade passiert und sich verraten fühlen davon, wenn es vielleicht eine
Koalition mit der AfD gibt.
Das heißt, eine Verbindung, glaube ich, in all diesen Bereichen ist auf jeden
Fall, sich mit Leuten kurz zu schließen, auszutauschen, denen es ähnlich geht möglicherweise.
Also das finde ich gerade in so einem Beamtenkontext total interessant.
Also sich zu überlegen oder mal Leute anzusprechen, wer beschäftigt sich denn
noch mit dieser Frage, AfD übernimmt meine Behörde, was kann ich da tun?
Und das ist so ein erster Schritt.
Bleiben wir nochmal bei diesen von dir angesprochenen Gruppen und fangen wir
vielleicht mal mit den Beamten an, weil die es vielleicht in gewisser Hinsicht auch als erstes spüren.
Weil das sind ja die unmittelbaren Auswirkungen, haben wir ja schon angesprochen.
Maßnahmen, Personalwechsel, Änderung der Dienstvorschriften,
Änderung von wie es getan wird, was so Konvention im Hause ist etc.
Was kann denn nun eine beamtete Person,
die ja nun qua Gesetz auch zu Dienen des Staates sozusagen verpflichtet ist
und gar nicht jetzt so viel Freiheit hat, nicht streiken kann, konkret tun?
Es gibt das Remonstrationsrecht, beziehungsweise die Remonstrationspflicht sogar.
Die besagt nämlich, dass BeamtInnen rechtswidrige Befehle gar nicht aus,
oder rechtswidrige Weisungen heißt das dann ja, nicht ausführen dürfen.
Die haben sogar eine Pflicht, das zu verweigern.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal ich als Polizist, ich kriege die Anweisung,
eine Person festzunehmen und es ist ja offensichtlich, ich darf das eigentlich gar nicht.
Oder ich habe die Anweisung, jemanden zu kontrollieren, ich darf das eigentlich gar nicht.
Dann habe ich die Pflicht dazu, das nicht zu machen.
Und dieses Remonstrationsrecht ist einerseits sehr interessant,
andererseits irgendwann auch zahnlos leider.
Also ich habe die Pflicht erstmal zu sagen, nein.
Dann sagt mein Vorgesetzter, machste doch.
Dann sage ich wieder nein, und zwar zu seinem Vorgesetzten. Dann sagt der,
machste doch. Und dann muss ich es machen.
Deswegen geht das jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig weit.
Auch wenn es wirklich rechtswidrig ist?
Dann habe ich aber nicht mehr die Verantwortung dafür. Und das ist natürlich
gerade in so einem Beamtenkontext immer die wichtigste Frage,
wer ist zuständig, wer ist am Schluss verantwortlich.
Nicht nur im Beamtenkontext, aber auch da.
Da ist es glaube ich zur Perfektion getrieben, diese Frage. Ja.
Und das ist vielleicht im Einzelfall nicht so wahnsinnig effektiv,
wenn wir jetzt aber in so einer Behörde Dutzende, Hunderte Leute haben,
die alle remonstrieren, die alle nicht befolgen, dann glaube ich, ist das was Effektives.
Und das ist glaube ich erstmal so das Basic. Also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass eine AfD eine Behörde übernimmt und dann wird alles umgesetzt.
Genauso wie, wenn die Grünen jetzt an die Behörde kommen, passiert ja auch nicht
einfach alles, was die wollen, sondern dann haben wir immer noch einen Prozess,
der der Umsetzung vorgeschaltet ist.
Und Beamtinnen können erstmal nicht durchsetzen.
Dann ist die Frage, okay, ja aus irgendeinem Grund muss man es trotzdem machen,
dann können die natürlich, Beamtinnen haben natürlich vielfältige Möglichkeiten,
Sachen sehr ausführlich zu prüfen.
Das kennst du, das kennst du natürlich.
Gibt es so eine Statistik, der, wenn du über alle IFG-Anfragen und sonstigen
Dinge überfragst, den Staat und so weiter, wenn man die Wartezeiten summiert,
gibt es dafür schon eine Einheit?
Ich habe schon ein Frag den Staat gewartet. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube beim vorletzten Kongress hatten wir, da wurde eine Anfrage ans Verkehrsministerium
gerade ein Jahr alt auf diesem Kongress und dann haben wir mit allen so ein
Geburtstagslied im großen Saal gesungen. Das war eigentlich ganz schön für die Anfrage.
Genau, man kann es sehr sorgfältig prüfen und es können sich immer neue Rechtsfragen
ergeben und man kann ein bisschen unterschiedlich priorisieren und auch das
kann man natürlich zu einer ziemlich extremen Form bringen.
Und auch wenn man damit dann nicht vorankommt, weil vielleicht die Leute um
einen selbst unnötig motiviert sind, kann man sich versetzen lassen,
nicht Teil davon sein und ich würde sagen, im Zweifelsfall immer weg.
Oder man kann sich krank schreiben lassen.
Hey, super Möglichkeiten als Beamtin.
Und solange ich krank geschrieben bin, wird mein Platz nicht nachbesetzt und
ich muss auch nichts machen.
Das heißt, da so ein bisschen kreativ zu werden und zu schauen,
wie kann ich denn jetzt in diesem Betrieb jetzt nicht als Person auffallen,
die besonders mitmacht.
Die Dienstnachvorschrift Antifa.
Ja, siehste. Da haben wir doch noch so eins für den Meme.
Wegen Krankheit heute nicht da, Dienstnachvorschrift Antifa.
Endlich mal so ein Ding, was ohne das Wort trotzdem auskommt Das ist doch eigentlich
Das Ding könnte man echt eigentlich mal auf dem leeren Schreibtisch,
Ja, die ist nach Vorschrift antifa, die rettet die Welt,
Okay Soviel mal zu den Beamten vielleicht, dann hast du noch die CDU genannt,
Und ist das die einzige Partei, auf die es jetzt noch ankommt?
Also tatsächlich kommt es wahnsinnig stark auf die an, glaube ich.
Also es ist ja so eine große Richtungsfrage für die Union jetzt.
Wenn man sich anschaut, in fast allen anderen Ländern der EU,
die Schwesterparteien der CDU, die koalieren alle mit Rechtsaußen.
Also sei es irgendwie die Partido Popular in Spanien, die mit Vox koalieren,
sei es in den Niederlanden jetzt die, die mit Red Wilders was zusammen machen,
in Österreich die Koalition mit der FPÖ,
die wir noch gut kennen vom Ibiza-Video.
Die Schwesterparteien von der Union machen das, die Union hat es bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Und da ist dann natürlich die große Frage, wie kriegen wir denn dazu, dass das auch so bleibt.
Und es gibt durchaus Stimmen in der Union, so vielleicht dann eher auf den Hinterbänken
der Parlamente, die tauschen sich jetzt schon aus und fänden es eigentlich ganz
gut, da mal irgendwie eine andere Koalition zu machen.
Und das ist so ein großer Richtungsstreit innerhalb der Union.
Ich würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen dazu aufzurufen, da einzutreten,
um Stimmung zu machen, aber es ist schon irgendwie die Frage,
wie die Mehrheiten innerhalb der Partei so organisiert werden,
dass es halt nicht dazu kommt.
Da bin ich aber beruhigt, dass wir jetzt hier auch noch in die CDU eintreten müssen.
Aber sonst gehst du mit deinen Maßnahmen schon relativ weit.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du einen Eindruck davon ich habe relativ wenig,
Berührungspunkte, muss ich sagen mit der CDU also ich habe auch relativ wenig
Berührungspunkte mit anderen Parteien, also jetzt nicht inhaltlicher Natur sondern
halt so konkret dass ich jetzt so ein Gefühl dafür habe wie die so ticken innerhalb ihrer,
Parteistruktur was so da so die Gefühlslage Ist bei der CDU,
weil ich meine auf der einen Seite ist ja natürlich der Erfolg der AfD für sie
auch im Prinzip eine Niederlage,
weil sie sich immer aufgestellt haben als rechts von uns darf es nichts geben
und so und jetzt gibt es da eine ganze Menge,
was halt auch Relevanz erhält, also Relevanz durch Wählerstimmen und durch nichts anderes.
Denkst du, die ziehen da mit?
Die sind wahnsinnig zerrissen. Also zwischen,
auf der einen Seite, wir haben ja echt komische Konstellationen in manchen Ostbundesländern,
wo die Umfragewerte so sind, dass man sagen muss, also die CDU,
wenn sie eine Koalition wollen,
müssen sie halt entweder mit der Linkspartei oder der AfD machen.
Und es gibt in der Union, würde ich sagen, gleich viele Leute,
die unter keinen Umständen mit der Linkspartei koalieren würden,
wie unter keinem Umständen mit der AfD.
Und das ist so ein Kampf und dann hast du halt Leute wie zum Beispiel in Sachsen-Anhalt
irgendwelche Landtagsabgeordnete, die vor ein paar Jahren gefordert haben,
man müsse jetzt mal das Soziale mit dem Nationalen verbinden.
Da gab es so eine Denkschrift von Abgeordneten.
Das heißt, auch die Leute gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Und das sind wahnsinnig erbitterte Kämpfe innerhalb der Parteien.
Also jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr, weiß ich nicht, im katholischen Münsterland
irgendwie oder wo Laschet, Armin Laschet ist.
Also das ist irgendwie dann so eine andere katholische CDU.
Die sind da glaube ich ein bisschen ferner von. Aber so andere CDU,
die sind einfach näher dran an der AfD, auch in ihrer Rhetorik.
Und da werden die nächsten Jahre, glaube ich, ganz schön hart.
Also auch für so eine CDU-Bundespartei, da alle zusammenzuhalten,
weil die einzelnen Bundesländer in total unterschiedliche Richtungen laufen.
Du glaubst also, also meinst du, die würden sich dann untereinander auch irgendwie
streiten darüber? rüber?
Das passiert jetzt schon, ja ja. Also Friedrich Merz hat jetzt vor kurzem beim
ich glaube es war der Bundesparteitag,
in Apolda wenn ich mich nicht irre dann so eine Kehrtwende gemacht,
der hat ja irgendwann mal die Grünen als den größten Feind bezeichnet und dann
wurde er dafür kritisiert, weil ja vielleicht sind es nicht die Grünen,
sondern die AfD und dann hat er jetzt eine Kehrtwende gemacht und hat gesagt,
ja notfalls müssen wir auch mit den Grünen koalieren und da war Todesstille
im Raum Also ich glaube, diese Streits, die passieren schon.
Das glaube ich ja, dass die inhaltlicher Natur stattfinden. Aber glaubst du,
dass es innerhalb der Union dann jetzt auch, sag ich mal, keine Ahnung,
das eine Bundesland macht es, das andere noch nicht.
Meckern die dann übereinander?
Ich habe bei der CDU immer so ein bisschen oder bei den sagen wir mal einfach
bei den CDU, CSU Leuten immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die,
frei sind von der Last des Idealismus,
sodass sie letztendlich nicht wirklich so etwas machen würden wie,
was weiß ich, aus der Partei austreten, weil sie jetzt mit den Faschisten koaliert.
Ich glaube, es würden viele tun. Ich glaube, viele würden austreten.
Ja, aber das sind dann die, die da ohnehin, also ja, austreten ist denkbar und
dann gibt es halt weniger Geld.
Dafür sterben ein paar Fascho-Boomer und die Kohle kommt wieder rein. Nein.
Glaubst du, es würden auch Leute, die in einer solchen Organisation sich schon
in Amt und Würden gekleidet sehen,
glaubst du, die hätten noch so viel Idealismus oder Rückgrat nach dieser Behandlung,
dass sie dann da austreten würden und dass da ein Bruch in der CDU oder nennenswerte
Brüche in der CDU zu erwarten wären?
Also ich glaube, so ein Jens Spahn, der würde mitmachen und wäre voll dabei bei so einer Koalition.
Wenn er dann an der Spitze davon stehen kann.
Das wollte ich nämlich genau sagen.
Naja, also ein ganz interessanter Vergleich ist vielleicht, was innerhalb der
FDP passiert ist, als die in so einem Wahl-Fuck-Up vor ein paar Jahren in Thüringen
auf einmal den Ministerpräsidenten-Posten hatten.
Können wir das nochmal ganz kurz zusammen, kurz wiederholen, was da...
Genau, also in Thüringen mit ihren komischen Machtverhältnissen war es so, vor drei, vier Jahren,
dass bei der Ministerpräsidentenwahl Bodo Ramelow von der Linken,
der vorher Ministerpräsident war, nicht die erforderliche Mehrheit bekommen hat.
Und dann in einem...
Interessanten Verfahren, um das mal so zu nennen, der FDP-Chef in Thüringen,
Kemmerling, Kemmerich, Kemmerling,
Kemmerling, ist das so ein Schnaps oder so? Kümmerling, na gut.
Aber Kümmerling wäre auch ein ganz angemessener Name in dem Zusammenhang gewesen.
Genau, Kemmerich dann mit den Stimmen unter anderem von der AfD gewählt wurde
zum Ministerpräsidenten und das führte dann dazu, dass es so ein ikonisches Bild gab,
wie Björn Höcke, der Thüringer AfD-Chef, der ja Faschist ist,
dem dann neuen Ministerpräsidenten Kemmerich gratulierte.
Und da gibt es so ein ikonisches Gratulationsfoto und gleichzeitig ähnlich ikonisch
wie die Thüringer Fraktionsvorsitzende ihren Glückwunsch Blumenstrauß ihm vor die Füße warf.
Und da war sehr interessant, was es für eine Dynamik gab innerhalb von wenigen Stunden.
Zum einen gab es riesige Demos, also vergleichsweise riesige Demos vor der FDP-Zentrale
in Berlin, vor dem Landtag in Thüringen dagegen.
Und die haben Eindruck gemacht und dann gab es ein paar Leute,
unter anderem Dorothee Bär von der CSU, die haben schnell gratuliert.
Hey, toll, ist ja egal, wie du gewählt wurdest oder vielleicht auch ganz gut,
dass du mit Stimmen der AfD gewählt wurdest.
Die dann aber ihre Glückwunsch-Tweets relativ schnell gelöscht haben,
also von irgendwo dann anscheinend eine Ansage oder einen Anschiss bekommen
haben oder das nochmal re-evaluiert haben.
Und dann hat Christian Lindner, der FDP-Chef der Bundespartei,
dem Vernehmen nach gedroht, wenn ihr das noch weiter so macht in Thüringen,
dann bin ich weg. Und dann fällt hier die Partei zusammen.
Und dann ist Kemmerich nach wenigen Tagen abgetreten.
Und so eine Dynamik grundsätzlich könnte ich mir durchaus auch vorstellen im
Zusammenhang mit irgendwie so einer Koalition in, sagen wir mal Sachsen-Anhalt oder so mit der AfD.
Aber gleichzeitig total wahnsinnig, also wahnsinnig schwer vorauszusagen.
Aber da haben wir dann wirklich so ein Clusterfakt mit verschiedenen Interessen
und einem föderalen System.
Und das Bittere dabei ist ja, im Zweifelsfall profitieren, wenn es derartige
Konflikte gibt und die aber schon gewählt sind, eigentlich kann es immer davon
ausgehen, profitiert dann wieder die AfD, ne?
So, was gibt es denn noch in den anderen Gruppen noch zu tun?
Also CDU braucht Rückgrat, Beamte können mindestens remonstrieren.
Was macht die Justiz?
Na, das hatten wir vorhin ja schon ein bisschen angesprochen,
die sind zum Glück so ein bisschen behebiger, aber da geht es eher um die Frage,
wie geht man um mit rechten RichterInnen und wie kann man da das Dienstrecht
vor allem anwenden, dass die eher entfernt werden.
Also, was ja ein bisschen durch die Medien ging in den letzten Monaten,
waren diese Putsch- und Anschlagspläne von dieser Gruppe Reus,
die jetzt auch alle in U-Haft sitzen und da gehen jetzt gerade die Prozesse gegen die alle los.
Die wollten dann unter anderem den Gesundheitsminister in Haft nehmen,
die wollten Exekutionen veranstalten und so weiter.
Das ist aber nicht von der FDGO gedeckt, oder?
Das ist haarscharf dran vorbei, würde ich sagen.
Thema verfehlt.
Und Justizministerin in der neuen Regierung,
die diese Gruppe Reuss nach dem Putsch geplant hat, war eine AfD-Politikerin,
eine ehemalige AfD-Bundestagsabgeordnete, Birgit Malsack-Winkemann.
Die sitzt jetzt im Gefängnis wegen dieser rechtsterroristischen Putschpläne und die war Richterin.
Also die war in Berlin am Landgericht Richterin und das viele Jahre lang.
Das heißt, daraus kann man glaube ich schlussfolgern, es wird jetzt nicht nur
Birgit gewesen sein, sondern es sind durchaus auch andere Personen in der Justiz,
die derartige Ansichten haben und da ist dann eher die große Frage,
wie kann man es schaffen, dass die halt aus diesem...
Wichtigen Amt entfernt werden und das ist dann letztlich eine dienstrechtliche
Frage, das mehr durchzusetzen.
Weil die Parteien bei Wiederholungswahlen keine neuen Kandidaten aufstehen dürfen.
Ihr Wahlergebnis konnte sie um 0,2 Prozentpunkte leicht verbessern,
obwohl sie weiter im Gefängnis sitzt und unter Terrorverdacht steht.
Das sagt auch eine Menge darüber aus, warum Leute die AfD wählen.
Bestimmt nicht wegen des Personals.
Wahlkreis 79 bitte weiträumig umfahren. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Wahlkreis 79 in Berlin, wo ist denn das überhaupt?
Ja, wo ist das wohl?
Ich tippe auf Steglitz.
Ja, Steglitz-Zillendorf. Okay, naja.
Seufz. Der Westen macht nur Ärger.
Ja, okay.
Wenn man sich aber anschaut, wie
wenig tatsächlich Rechtsprechungen veröffentlicht ist, dann ist das krass.
Von allen Entscheidungen von deutschen Gerichten sind nämlich nach einer Erhebung
nur 0,9 Prozent aller Entscheidungen verfügbar.
So, das heißt eine von, ich glaube, 111 Entscheidungen wird nur veröffentlicht
im Internet und die anderen nicht.
Und das kann eben dann auch dazu führen, dass so eine Birgit die ganze Zeit
vielleicht als Einzelrichterin hier und da Entscheidung fällt und die vielleicht
auch irgendwie im AfD Sinne fällt und das aber niemandem auffällt außerhalb
dieses Gerichts, weil niemand das mitbekommt.
Und da haben wir ein sehr konkretes Transparenzproblem, was dann auch eine Kontrolle
von der Justiz und vielleicht auch eine Kontrolle von systemischen Problemen darin verunmöglicht.
Deswegen ist, obwohl das so ein bisschen mittelbar scheint,
mehr Transparenz im Justizsystem ein total wichtiger Schritt,
also eine standardmäßige Veröffentlichung von Entscheidungen,
ein total wichtiger Schritt für Kontrolle dann auch von solchen Rechten.
Wir können hier den kleinen Exkurs machen, dass du deswegen gerade angeklagt bist.
Für die Veröffentlichung von Gerichtsentscheidungen?
In meinem Fall ist es keine Entscheidung, wobei doch, ja, nee, hast recht.
Ja, da ist das Verfahren noch laufend, deswegen ist das eine Straftat.
Kannst du das kurz erläutern?
Also Erläuterung, ich mach's mal wahrscheinlich, damit du dich nicht weiter reinredest.
Wenn ich den Fall richtig in Erinnerung habe, du hast gerade das Problem ja
schon benannt, Gerichtsverfahren sind größtenteils, oder Gerichtsentscheidungen sind wenig öffentlich.
Ihr habt bei Frag den Staat über Ermittlungsmaßnahmen gegen die letzte Generation
berichtet und dabei auch Gerichtsentscheidungen.
Nein, nein, nein, jetzt redest du mich rein. Nicht Frag den Staat hat das gemacht, ich habe das gemacht.
Frag den Staat ist ein gemeinnütziger Verein, die würden sowas nicht machen.
Das habe ich gemacht, zwar bei Frag den Staat, aber ich als Einzelperson, auch ganz allein.
Ich habe auch die Grafiken gemacht, ich habe alles gemacht. Okay, du Einzeltäter?
Ich habe es auch gehostet, alles. Ich habe alles gemacht.
Okay, absoluter Einzeltäter hier.
Einzelfall. Aber du hast über Ermittlungsmaßnahmen gegen die letzte Generation
berichtet und mehrere Gerichtsentscheidungen veröffentlicht und dabei auch gezielt
die Strafanzeigen riskiert,
die du dann bekommen hast.
Und dieser Fall ist dann vor das Landgericht gegangen
und das ist auch quasi kalkuliertes Ziel
der ganzen Angelegenheit und du wendest dich zusammen mit der Gesellschaft für
Freiheitsrechte gegen Paragraf 353d Nummer 3 StGB und ihr seht den als verfassungswidrig,
weil er die Pressefreiheit einschränkt.
Genau, weil in laufenden Strafverfahren solche Entscheidungen zu veröffentlichen
seit Ewigkeiten eine Straftat ist.
Und das wird verhandelt im Landgericht am 16. und 18. Oktober.
Wo kann man die Tickets, ach so, nicht zocken.
Wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt, nee, es ist eine Straftat,
darf man nicht veröffentlichen. Und da geht es dann so ein bisschen zur Sache.
Ich glaube, es wird jetzt weniger um den Sachverhalt an sich gehen,
weil ich ja geständig bin. Deswegen ist das, glaube ich, alles nicht so schlimm.
Okay, aber jetzt geht es ja nicht um deine Rettung, sondern wir wollen ja das
Grundgesetz retten und uns alle.
Da muss jetzt dein Fall erstmal ein bisschen hinten anstehen.
Ja, weil es nebenbei, nebenbei, ach so, ja, Ja, Arne, darf ich dich darauf hinweisen,
dass du da demnächst beiden vorgerichtet bist? Ja, aber ich bin ja geständig.
Naja, aber in einer Weise hängt es glaube ich schon mit diesem anderen Thema
zusammen. Danke, danke.
Weil? Weil ich glaube, dass Angriff die beste Verteidigung ist und dass es dafür ganz gut passt.
Also wir glaube ich nicht grundsätzlich in so einen Modus verfallen sollten,
wo wir einfach nur schauen, was ist jetzt der Status Quo, wie können wir den
verteidigen, sondern eher zu schauen,
wie können wir denn dafür sorgen, dass es besser wird und dann ist dieser Kampf
dafür, dass es besser wird, also für mehr Presseverhalten in diesem Fall eben
auch eine Verteidigung dagegen, dass eine AfD zum Beispiel das einschränken will.
Kommen wir nochmal zur Presse.
Erstattung bekommen hat, weil er war halt irgendwie so der Irre, der Irre-Kandidat.
Ach, jetzt kommt auch noch der Trump.
Na toll.
Der haut ja ganz schön was raus. Und dann haben wir ja mittlerweile so eine
Medienwelt, die immer nach Klicks heischt und die immer irgendwie die Aufmerksamkeit verfolgt und,
so ein bisschen dieses, was ist berichtenswürdig sich ein wenig unter die Prämisse
stellt, was nützt mir und nicht so sehr, was nützt jetzt der Gesellschaft.
Wie ist dein Blick auf die Medienlandschaft in diesem Fall?
Ich habe den Eindruck, über Talkshows ist schon so wahnsinnig viel geredet worden.
Da waren wir uns darüber einig, möglichst viele von der AfD einladen,
um sie dann bloß ihre dummen Gedanken bloßzustellen.
Genau, bis jetzt sind alle JournalistInnen daran gescheitert,
die bloßzustellen, aber wenn ich die einlade, dann werde ich die auf jeden Fall, dann aber.
Ja, wir sollten die mal einladen, dann bleibt ja nichts mehr übrig.
Es ist so eine komische Hybris, so eine komische Selbstüberschätzung,
dann zu denken, alle anderen haben es nicht geschafft und ich jetzt schon.
Die spielen ja auf einem anderen Spielfeld, also für die ist ja egal,
ob sie jetzt die Wahrheit sagen oder nicht und deswegen ist allein so ein Überführen
in der Regel ja auch schon gar nicht möglich. Es gibt so ein ganz tolles Interview
mit Björn Höcke, das mal geführt wurde, das mag ich wirklich.
ZDF war das glaube ich vor einigen Jahren, da hat,
das war super clever, der ZDF-Journalist vorher Passagen aus Björn Höckes Buch
anderen AfD-Abgeordneten vorgelesen und hat die raten lassen,
ist das jetzt aus meinem Kampf oder aus Björn Höckes Buch.
Und die sind total in Schwimmen gekommen und diese Interviews hat er dann Björn
Höcke gezeigt und hat gesagt, was sagen sie denn dazu.
Und der Typ ist so davon aus der Fassung gebracht worden, dass er dieses Gespräch
dann abgebrochen hat und dann hat sein Pressesprecher gesagt,
also sinngemäß, das Interview hätte jetzt den Herrn Höcke aber emotional so mitgenommen,
das müsse man nochmal machen. Und das war wirklich ganz toll.
Das hat wirklich entwaffnet, aber das war jetzt auch wirklich ein sehr besonderes Interview.
Also wenn alle so gemacht werden, meinetwegen auch gern das.
Aber ansonsten ist es natürlich nicht zielführend. Also wenn es irgendwie diese
großen Demokratie-Proteste gibt im Januar und dann wird die AfD eingeladen,
um zu sagen, ja was halten sie denn davon,
dass gegen sie demonstriert wird, anstatt die Organisatoren einzuladen und zu
fragen, warum demonstrieren sie denn?
Dann ist das natürlich auch ein Schlag ins Gesicht.
Aber sag mal, wie...
Wie kamen die darauf?
Also ist das irgendwie...
Ich sitze nicht in so einer Redaktion drin.
Ist das vielleicht auch wirklich ein Muster? Ist das vielleicht einfach grundsätzlich
so, dass wenn Leute demonstrieren, dass sie möglichst nicht zu Wort kommen?
Ja, vielleicht, weil es da dann dieses Vorurteil gibt, die seien betroffen und
damit zu emotional und nicht geeignet.
Also vielleicht ist da irgendwie eine falsche Wahrnehmung davon,
dass die in irgendeiner Weise parteiisch wären, wobei natürlich,
hey, wenn du die AfD anreichst, die sind natürlich auch parteiisch.
Aber ja, das sind die Talkshows, ich glaube, da können wir ewig drüber reden.
Das ist, vielleicht gibt es eher eine kleinere Maßnahme, die glaube ich total
sinnvoll wäre und die wäre die Depublizierungspflicht für Öffentlich-Rechtliche
zumindest im Informationsbereich abzuschaffen.
Also ist es jetzt so, und das habe ich jetzt fürs Buch wiedergemerkt,
es gibt so wahnsinnig viele tolle Recherchen von den Investigativabteilungen
bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
ganz viel zur AfD und wenn du
die von vor drei, vier, fünf Jahren dir anschauen willst, ist alles weg,
ist alles nicht mehr da, musst du alles irgendwie übers Internet Archive gehen,
wenn du Glück hast, dass es da ist, irgendwie über archivierte Seiten,
das ist alles nicht mehr im Erstlink zu finden,
weil das nach dem Medienstaatsvertrag und den dazugehörigen Dokumenten depubliziert.
Werden muss nach gewissen Fristen.
Und das ist ein dermaßen unsinniges Konzept.
Also da könnte man schreien, wenn man sich das anschaut.
Überall reden alle über Desinformation und wie können wir damit umgehen und
das ganze Fake News Kram und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir da einen öffentlich-rechtlichen mit einem Wahnsinnsbudget
mit tollen Leuten, die Informationen.
Gesicherte, gute investigative Informationen bereitstellen und dann verpflichten
wir die dazu, das wieder rauszunehmen aus dem Internet. Also es ist dermaßen widersinnig.
Das wurde aber irgendwann, also da war ich bei Netzpolitik.org,
als das irgendwie entschieden wurde. So 2010, 11 oder sowas.
Da gab es immer wieder neue Aufwasche für und jetzt ist Medienstaatsvertrag
nicht mehr der Rundfunkstaatsvertrag.
Warum eigentlich? Ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern.
Also so grundsätzlich ist das der Bereich, da kann dann Leonard Dobusch wahrscheinlich
dozieren, wenn wir den nochmal fragen. Aber grundsätzlich ist das der Bereich,
wo die privaten Medien sagen, hey, das ist ja eine Konkurrenz zu uns.
Und wenn ihr mit dem Rundfunkbeitrag finanziert, Inhalte aufbaut,
die uns dann das Geschäftsmodell kaputt machen, dann ist das ein Problem.
Also jetzt sehr zugespitzt, aber das ist ungefähr der Bereich und deswegen müssen
verschiedene Bereiche des öffentlichen Rundfunks nach unterschiedlichen Fristen gelöscht werden.
Da gibt es so ein paar Ausnahmen, schönerweise, weil die Wikimedia über dann
zum Beispiel die Wikipedia so ein paar Kooperationen gemacht hat mit Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
wo deren Inhalte unter freien Lizenzen bereitgestellt werden.
Ha, toller Hack, weil du die dann natürlich weiterverwenden kannst,
in irgendwie Wiki, in Comments und so weiter reinladen kannst und die dann auch
unabhängig von den Depublizierungspflichten halt an anderen Orten weiter nutzen kannst.
Deswegen ist so dieser Bereich der Lizensierung und der freien Lizensierung
ein total gutes Mittel, um öffentlich-rechtliche Inhalte auch dauerhaft online zu halten.
Eines der Probleme ist natürlich, dass der gesamte Kontext dieser Problematik
dort halt auch nicht so richtig gesehen wird oder zumindest bis vor kurzem noch nicht gesehen wurde.
Ich habe auch mal einen Vortrag über Podcasting und Medienzukunft,
was man halt so ab und zu mal macht, beim Deutschlandfunk gehalten und bin dann
halt auch so auf Podcasts und öffentlich-rechtliche Medien gekommen und dann
habe ich halt den Raum gefragt,
warum denn eigentlich die Mülltonnen nicht brennen würden hier draußen.
Dann haben die mich eigentlich alles ein bisschen komisch angeguckt,
weil sie nicht so genau wussten, was da ist.
So, ja, ihr müsst euch hier brennende Mülltonnen haben und euch dagegen wehren,
dass irgendwie eure Relevanz eigentlich in die Tonne getreten wird,
weil wenn man euch einfach löschen kann nach ein paar Jahren,
dann löscht ihr einfach eure eigene Relevanz und ihr macht euch immer so eine
Angst um eure Zukunft hier und seid am Klagen, aber tut halt auch nichts.
Ja, wussten sie auch nicht so richtig was dazu zu sagen.
Klar, es gibt dann so Detailprobleme wie Copyright,
Nutzungsrechte, dann ist ja sozusagen für all diese Beiträge sind ja dann die
Nutzungsrechte nicht für alle Ewigkeiten und dann auch nicht für das Internet ausgehandelt worden.
Da ist jetzt zumindest, ich glaube, einiges nachverhandelt worden.
Es geht halt, wenn es sein muss. Das wissen wir auch immer.
Also es ist nicht unmöglich und ich halte das eben auch für einen wichtigen
politischen Prozess, dass sich vor allem die öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien,
solange es sie noch gibt, dass sie sich mal darauf besinnen,
dass es sie vielleicht auch noch länger geben sollte.
Denn das ist schon eine Errungenschaft.
Und die Lust, öffentlichen Rundfunk unter eine politische Kontrolle zu bekommen,
da müssen wir nicht weit gucken.
Ungarn, Polen, da haben wir das alles schon gesehen. Jetzt gerade in der Slowakei
gibt es ähnliche Bestrebungen, auch wenn das jetzt ein bisschen unklar ist nach
diesem Attentat auf den Vizovista weitergeht.
Aber das ist halt immer wieder so ein Ding.
Öffentlich-rechtliche Medien, freie Medien sind für Faschisten einfach eine Gefahr.
Und dementsprechend wollen sie die halt auch auslöschen und wir müssen halt
an der Stelle auch dafür sorgen, dass das einfach besser wird,
weil wir können es ja mit unserem Podcast allein auch nicht regeln.
Fast, aber nicht ganz.
So, Medienschälte abgeschlossen. Was machen die Gewerkschaften?
Generalstreiks vielleicht.
Arbeitskämpfen, Streiks und so geprägt hat. Unter anderem, dass Gewerkschaften.
Schadensersatzpflichtig sind im Falle von solchen Streiks, die,
Arbeitskampfferneziele haben. Und das hat damals dazu geführt,
dass die Gewerkschaften sich zurückgezogen haben aus diesem politischen Business
und sich eher darauf fokussieren.
Was es halt im Umfeld von so Tarifkämpfen, Auseinandersetzungen gibt.
Und dadurch, dass es aber Rechtsprechung ist.
Kann man die natürlich auch ändern. Und da wäre so die, glaube ich, interessante Frage,
auch wenn das jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Spaziergang ist, aber wie man denn jetzt
schon vorsorgen kann für so einen Fall, wo man einen Generalstreik bräuchte
und wie man politische Streiks ein bisschen mehr en vogue bringt.
Wie man ein bisschen französische Verhältnisse hier schaffen kann auf deutschen
Straßen und wie man vielleicht mit einem gut gewählten Fall versucht,
nochmal zum Bundesarbeitsgericht zu kommen und vielleicht zu schauen,
dass vielleicht in Einzelfällen doch politische Streiks möglich sind.
Das ist eher so der Bereich, den ich sehr interessant finde und über den ja
auch mehr jetzt nachdenken.
Es gibt dieses Bündnis, das heißt wir fahren zusammen von Verdi und Fridays
for Future und das ist total clever,
weil da Fridays for Future für Klimaschutz kämpft, gleichzeitig Verdi für bessere
Tarifbedingungen im öffentlichen Nahverkehr und die bringen das dann zusammen
und tun diese beiden Themen total clever zusammen, weil sie dann unterschiedliche Zielgruppen haben.
Und dann natürlich, wer die auch auf einer Demo ist, wo Klimaschutz gefordert
wird, obwohl die das eigentlich jetzt erstmal nicht so einfach können.
Und solche kreativen Lösungen und vielleicht auch juristische,
strategische Klagelösungen finde ich grundsätzlich interessant.
Und Gewerkschaften einfach als Player wahrzunehmen, der in so einem Fall von
einer AfD-Machtübernahme vielleicht sagt, wir legen jetzt unsere Werkzeuge nieder.
Mit welcher Forderung? Also Generalstreik schön und gut also zumindest,
ohne mich jetzt lange mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt zu haben,
ich wusste nur man darf keinen Generalstreik hab ich mir gemerkt mach lieber
nicht diese Woche nicht mehr,
zumindest kann man ja argumentieren, okay okay, wenn der Streik wird im Zweifelsfall
dem betroffenen Unternehmen schaden,
und potenziell kann das ja wirklich nichts dafür. Also eventuell,
wenn jetzt was weiß ich, der Generalstreik bei dem und dem Unternehmen,
ich will jetzt gar keins benennen, das hat ja vielleicht echt keine Schuld,
dass die AfD gewählt wurde. Ja.
Finde ich jetzt halbwegs okay, dann auch zu sagen,
naja, dann, das Unternehmen hat ja quasi keine Handlungsmöglichkeit,
den Missstand, gegen den der Generalstreik sich richtet, abzustellen.
Aber vielleicht mit einem Interesse daran, dass die AfD sich nicht an der Regierung halten kann.
Und wie soll das Unternehmen das dann machen? Also okay, Heckler & Koch hätte
eine Option, aber es gibt ja jetzt wenig, also was weiß ich,
nehmen wir die Supermarktkette.
Was sollen die jetzt machen?
Also die Idee bei einem Generalstreik ist ja zu zeigen, dass so eine gewisse
Form der öffentlichen Ordnung nicht aufrechterhalten wird, wenn X und Y passiert.
Und wenn das Szenario ist, die AfD kommt an die Macht und plant dann die Demokratie abzuschaffen,
dann würde ich sagen, ist das eine Legitimierung, um zu sagen,
okay, die wollen das System abschaffen, dann legen wir das jetzt erstmal nieder
und dann könnt ihr mal schauen und darüber dann Druck aufzubauen.
Das ist ja grundsätzlich bei einem Generalstreik so die Forderung und wir könnten
uns jetzt das Szenario überlegen, die CDU will tatsächlich mit der AfD in eine
Koalition eintreten und da dann zu zeigen,
wenn ihr das macht, dann liegt hier erstmal alles still. Das ist so die Richtung.
Haben Unternehmen sonst noch Handlungsmöglichkeiten?
Sich klar zu positionieren auf jeden Fall. Also das passiert aber in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten schon mehr.
Aber natürlich kann man als Unternehmen sagen, wir vertreten demokratische Werte.
Wir glauben, dass AfD an der Regierung ein großes Problem wäre und das sowohl
nach außen zu zeigen als auch nach innen in den Betrieb.
Also man kann auch Betriebsvereinbarungen machen, in denen man sich gegenseitig
auf demokratische Werte verpflichtet.
Und das hat ja eine große Wirkkraft, weil man, wenn man sich,
überrascht mich immer wieder, auf solche Vertrauensbarometer zu schauen,
wem vertrauen die Deutschen eigentlich?
Und da sind die Arbeitgeber ganz weit vorne.
Würde man nicht denken, ja genau, aber es hat eine große identitätsstiftende
Wirkung bei vielen Menschen,
eine große Bindung, großes Vertrauen und dann macht das natürlich was, wenn die Firma sagt,
wir finden nur...
Wenn der Daimler sagt, da machen wir nicht mit.
Genau, da habe ich schon immer geschafft und wenn der das sagt, dann ja. Ja.
Du erinnerst dich aber sicherlich auch an diesen Februar an Edeka-Betreiber
in Sachsen und Thüringen, Herr Simmel, Edeka Simmel,
druckt in seinen Prospekt irgendwie sowas wie für Demokratie gegen Nazis und,
entschuldigt sich schleunigst danach dafür, weil er mit seinem Edeka halt echt Probleme bekommen hat.
Ja, weil in dem Fall die Freien Sachsen, also noch so eine AfD-ähnliche Gruppierung in,
Sachsen Kampagne gegen den gemacht hat, sehr koordiniert, so eine Hetzkampagne
und das hat den klein gemacht, das hat den total schnell mürbe gemacht.
Wahnsinn, ne?
Da gab es so ein paar krasse Zitate irgendwie von Leuten, die gesagt haben.
Die sich einfach identifiziert haben mit diesem Wort Nazi und gesagt haben, wie hier gegen uns.
Wie kannst du gegen Nazis sein? Was hast du gegen uns? Und das ist schon dann
natürlich krass und da merkt man dann aber auch, da hat dem dann eine Unterstützungsstruktur gefehlt.
Und das ist natürlich verrückt. Also ich meine, der hat mehrere Edeka-Märkte.
Eigentlich würde man sagen, der ist derjenige, der die Struktur bereitstellen muss.
Aber offenbar war der dann nicht gut genug eingebettet von Leuten,
die ihn beraten haben dabei.
So eine Kampagne, wenn die passiert, das kriegt man ja auch nicht immer mit,
dass das eine koordinierte Kampagne ist.
Sondern man denkt dann irgendwie, das sind einfach wahnsinnig viele Leute.
Und dabei ist das eigentlich über irgendwie die Telegram-Gruppe von Freien Sachsen da koordiniert.
Und da braucht es dann einfach Leute, die Beratungsangebote dazu wahrnehmen oder,
BeraterInnen, die schnell auf die Leute zugehen und sagen, toll,
dass du dich positioniert hast, das wird jetzt passieren. Wappne dich schon mal.
Ja, also wappne dich schon mal und vor allem auch irgendwie vermitteln,
also das geht halt weiter.
Üblicherweise zieht dieser Nazi-Zirkus weiter. Ich habe jetzt mit mehreren Leuten
auch schon zu tun, die dann vielleicht mal diesen Wanderzirkus auch vor der Haustür hatten.
Und der Rat ist dann eben, die sind auch bald wieder weg.
Man muss natürlich bei dem Edeka-Fall auch dazu sagen, so als Edeka-Supermarktbesitzer
bist du halt so ein kleiner Unternehmer im Prinzip.
Wir haben ja eben von großen Unternehmen gesprochen, das ist ja schon was anderes,
ob jetzt Daimler-Benz sich zu irgendetwas äußert oder jetzt irgendein Supermarktbesitzer,
selbst wenn er mehrere Filialen betreibt.
Na aber umso besser, wenn die das machen, weil das dann natürlich auch nochmal
unmittelbarer da ist, aber gleichzeitig sind die dann auch verletzlicher.
Also wäre auf jeden Fall angemessen, wenn jetzt der Unternehmensverbund,
der ja EDK letztlich ist,
sich dann auch da hätte positioniert, aber das weiß ich nicht,
ob die sich da für irgendwas interessiert haben in dem Zusammenhang.
Okay.
Man sieht an dem Ding aber schon, warum Unternehmen üblicherweise versuchen
aus diesem kontroversen Thema der Politik sich rauszuhalten.
Das sollte sich hoffentlich ändern. Aber es gab ja jetzt auch,
weil das nie wieder ist jetzt und so, da hatten sich glaube ich auch sehr viele.
Genau, viele DAX-Konzerne, die dann irgendwie befragt wurden und dann entweder
sehr schwurbelig oder teilweise auch sehr konkret gesagt haben,
Demokratie doch schon ganz gut, weil gut für die Wirtschaft.
Ja, Wirtschaft braucht Freiheit.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch gerade jetzt in Thüringen und in anderen Regionen
ein echtes Thema, weil natürlich das Aufkommen der AfD,
solche Projekte wie die Chip-Industrie, die ja dort zumindest geschafft hat,
sich ein gewisses Standbein zu organisieren,
massiv darunter gefährdet ist, dass Leute halt da nicht hinziehen wollen aus
fernen Ländern, die halt gebraucht werden.
Einfach weil man diese Expertise braucht, wenn man Hightech haben will.
Hightech kann man sich nicht einfach so herbei ausbilden nebenbei,
sondern da muss man eben auch mit Leuten arbeiten, die da einfach schon Firmen
sind in dem Thema und die denken sich halt auch so, warum soll ich meiner Familie diesen Stress zumuten.
Ich kann auch nach Kalifornien gehen oder nach Asien oder was weiß ich.
Von daher ist es ein wirtschaftliches Argument, was man hier machen kann und
ich denke, das muss man dann den Unternehmen, wenn sie es nicht schon selber
verstanden haben, auch nochmal klar machen. Aber jetzt kommen wir nochmal zu
dem interessanteren Teil, denke ich.
Die Zivilgesellschaft. Also wir.
You and me. Ja.
Was können wir tun?
Und wo siehst du da Hebel? Siehst du da überhaupt Hebel?
Und was hat das alles mit Netzpolitik zu tun?
Das ist überhaupt die Frage hier.
Ich hoffe, wir haben sie teilweise schon beantwortet.
Ja, teilweise angesprochen.
Also zum einen geht es ganz viel um Geld. Vor ein paar Folgen hattest du einen
Bundestagszusammenfasser hier und ich habe mal da nachgeschaut, was ist denn das Gesetz,
was am längsten jetzt rumliegt im Bundestag.
Und das ist das Demokratiefördergesetz.
Oh nein.
Also das Gesetz, das letztlich die Infrastruktur, die langfristige Finanzierung
sichern soll von Demokratieinitiativen und da gibt es gerade einfach Streit
in der Ampelkoalition und die FDP will das nicht.
Und das ist aber ein Kernproblem, was jetzt wahnsinnig viele Demokratieinitiativen
zum Jahreswechsel hatten.
Da gab es ja diese Haushaltssperre als Reaktion auf das Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
zum Klima- und Transformationsfonds und das hat dazu geführt,
dass aus dem Bundeshaushalt erstmal keine Gelder ausgegeben wurden.
Auch nicht an Demokratieinitiativen.
Und Ende Dezember wussten wahnsinnig viele Demokratieinitiativen,
also Leute, die irgendwie Beratung machen für Opfer von rechtsextremer Gewalt
zum Beispiel, die wussten nicht, ob sie in zwei Wochen noch einen Job haben,
weil das Geld nicht da war.
Weil die Finanzierung in dem Bereich grundsätzlich in der Regel über ein Jahr
läuft und nicht mehrjährig.
Da wird jedes Jahr neu entschieden, muss sich jedes Jahr einen neuen Antrag
machen und so halten sich die Behörden, diese Innies sehr kurz alleine.
Und das führt dazu, dass gerade jetzt um den Jahreswechsel in ganz vielen dieser
Initiativen die Leute einfach den Hut genommen haben und gesagt haben,
jetzt macht euren Scheiß doch selber.
Wir haben keinen Bock mehr darauf, jedes Jahr im Dezember nicht zu wissen,
ob wir nächstes Jahr noch einen Job haben.
Wir gehen jetzt irgendwie in einen
Bereich, wo wir auch mal mehrjährige Arbeitsverträge bekommen. kommen.
Und das finde ich so wahnsinnig interessant, so im Kontext dieser Demokratieproteste
im Januar, wo sich dann alle Politiker hinstellen und sagen,
ja, hier, toll, Demokratie, dies, das müssen wir verteidigen, wir stehen zusammen.
Und das wäre aber das eine konkrete Gesetz, die eine konkrete Initiative gewesen,
die genau das mal umgesetzt hätte.
Und dass die es nicht geschafft haben, dann zu sagen, okay, wir haben hier Millionen
auf der Straße, wir setzen das um, in wenigstens mal eingesetzt,
was sagt, was wir hier die ganze Zeit auf den Demos erzählen.
Das fand ich schon wahnsinnig enttäuschend.
Und letztlich geht es, glaube ich, bei ganz vielen dieser Demokratiefragen dann
letztlich ums Geld. Also wo kriegen die das Geld her?
Wenn die AfD an die Macht kommt, wird die natürlich solche Finanzierungsmittel streichen.
Das bedeutet, wir müssen private Finanzierungsstränge nochmal stärker irgendwie
in den Blick nehmen. Spenden gehören natürlich auch dazu.
Und das zählt natürlich, du wolltest den netzpolitischen Bezug,
auch für netzpolitische, zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen.
Ja, gute Überleitung.
Naja, also viele Initiativen, über die ihr hier eigentlich jede Woche sprecht,
die spendenfinanziert sind.
Und da zu spenden ist dann eben auch eine Präventionsarbeit und eine Demokratiearbeit.
Demokratiefördergesetz ist seit 429 Tagen in der Ausschussberatung,
steht hier und ist, wie du schon richtig angemerkt hast,
der Top-Eintrag in der Auflistung von zurückgelassenen Gesetzesinitiativen.
Der zweite Platz ist dann schon nur bei 246 Tagen.
Ja, okay, gut. Aber das ist natürlich etwas, was man jetzt für die Zivilgesellschaft mal tun sollte.
Die Frage ging ja eigentlich ein bisschen mehr so, was kann die Zivilgesellschaft an sich tun.
Das war dann auch so ein bisschen die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe,
als es zu den Demonstrationen kam, die durch den Korrektivbericht ausgelöst wurden,
wo dann alle so rumstanden und ich so ein bisschen genervt war von den Reden,
die dort gehalten wurden, weil da einerseits mantra-mäßig...
Ein bisschen repetitives,
Demonstrationsgeschrei von sich gegeben wurde und ich mir die ganze Zeit gedacht
habe, jetzt sind hier irgendwie so viele Leute, die mal einen Arsch hoch bekommen haben.
Wir haben ja von über einer Million Teilnehmern gesprochen.
Da kann man mal davon ausgehen, dass die Mehrheit nicht so zu den Demo-Gehern gehört.
Im Gegensatz zu dir?
Die wollen dann auch nicht im Kanon irgendwie leistet Widerstand singen oder so, ja?
Weil die nicht so der Brüller ist. Sondern die wollen da hingehen und wenn sie
überhaupt in der Lage sind zu hören, was da gesprochen wird,
dann vielleicht auch mal konkrete Handlungsanweisungen bekommen, ne?
Und das hat mir so ein bisschen gefehlt, dieses es kommt auf die Wahlen an.
Ich meine, man könnte es meinen, ja, na klar kommt es auf die Wahlen an,
aber wir müssen so die Wahlbeteiligung anschauen und dann wissen wir,
dass vielen Leuten nicht unbedingt immer klar ist, dass es auf die Wahlen ankommt.
Und von daher fehlt auch so ein bisschen die unmittelbare Ansprache.
Aber jenseits dieser Demonstrationen, glaube ich, ist es halt auch ein generelles
Gefühl einer Machtlosigkeit, die viele Leute so haben.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt so eine depressive, niedergeschlagene Machtlosigkeit,
sondern einfach eher so eine, was kann ich schon machen, Machtlosigkeit.
So ein, ja, was soll ich denn da jetzt machen,
das ist doch die Aufgabe von allen anderen und dann zeigen halt alle auf alle
anderen und das ist natürlich auch etwas,
was so ein faschistisches System sich gerne zunutze macht, dass eigentlich die
meisten Leute einfach in einem totalen Desinteresse oder in der Annahme,
sie könnten nichts beeinflussen, voranschreiten.
Ja, oder gar nicht mal voranschreiten, sondern einfach nur rumstehen.
Ja, und ich kann das total gut nachvollziehen, weil mir das auch oft so geht.
Also ich will jetzt gar nicht so einen optimistischen Sprech irgendwie raushauen
und sagen, das sind die drei Sachen, dann macht ihr das und dann ist alles gut
und wir schaffen das schon.
Ja, Call to Action müssen wir jetzt hier liefern.
Genau, ich sage trotzdem Sachen, ich sage nur, ich kann es total nachvollziehen
und ich glaube, man muss sich jetzt auch nicht den Druck machen,
dass man jetzt total enthusiastisch von Tag 1 sein muss.
Ich finde, trauern und verzweifelt sein ist vollkommen okay.
Also auch aus Familiengeschichte-Sicht einfach mal dazu sagen,
es ist okay, depressiv zu sein.
Aber ich glaube, was so ganz zentral ist und das finde ich in der Betrachtung
in dem Bereich so ganz interessant, ist Räume zu schaffen und Räume zu nutzen,
sich Räume zu nehmen. Und mit diesem Räumedenken kann man, glaube ich, ganz viel machen.
Wenn Leute auf die Straße gehen und demonstrieren, dann ist das ja auch erstmal
eine Form, sich den öffentlichen Raum anzueignen.
Wenn ich Sticker in meinem Kiez, so, dann nehme ich mir diesen Raum oder eigne
ihn mir an und bespiele den.
Wenn der CCC zum Congress einlädt, dann schafft der einen Raum,
den ich woanders in dieser Form nicht kenne, aus dem ganz viele Möglichkeiten entstehen.
Aus dem ich in der Regel dann wieder rausgehe und diese Machtlosigkeit vergessen
habe, weil ich dann irgendwie ganz viel mit...
Kannst du dich ins nächste Messer stoßen?
Also ich glaube zu versuchen Räume zu schaffen, es kann auch ein kulturelles
Zentrum sein oder es kann irgendwie ein Abend sein, zu dem man Leute einlädt.
So Räume für Begegnung zu schaffen, ist glaube ich total wichtig und damit irgendwie
demokratische Räume zu schaffen und das sind dann Dann zum einen physische Räume, glaube ich.
Also total interessant finde ich
da die, oder vorbildlich finde ich die Hanau-Initiative, Initiative 19.
Februar Hanau, die aus den Hinterbliebenen und Angehörigen von den Opfern vom
Terroranschlag, vom rechten Anschlag da vor vier Jahren besteht und deren Umfeld.
Und die sind mehrfach verraten worden.
Die sind von der Polizei verraten worden, sind wahnsinnig schlecht behandelt
worden, die kämpfen seit vielen Jahren für Aufklärung und trauern gleichzeitig
um ihre Angehörigen, die erschossen und verletzt wurden,
und die haben es geschafft, sich zusammenzuschließen und aus dieser traumatischen
Erfahrung sich nicht zurückzuziehen, obwohl ich das vollkommen okay und angemessen fände,
sondern die haben sich ein Ladenlokal in Hanau gemietet.
Und sind jetzt in der Innenstadt von Hanau und haben diesen Raum und sagen,
ihr wolltet uns umbringen und wir sind trotzdem da.
Die haben sich den Raum genommen gegen alle Widerstände. Und das finde ich einen
total wichtigen und in der Form inspirierenden Weg irgendwie über Sichtbarkeitmachung
im Raum dann auch Demokratiearbeit zu machen.
Und das ist der physische Bereich und natürlich geht das im Digitalen dann genauso.
Also nicht kommerzielle Orte im Internet irgendwie zu schaffen,
in der Wikipedia mitzuschreiben, so wahnsinnig nervig wie das ist,
aber das eben trotzdem zu machen und irgendwie diesen Prozess mitzugestalten
und Inhalte, auf die alle Leute frei zugreifen können, mitzugestalten.
Auch das, glaube ich, gehört dazu, weil es da dann letztlich darum geht,
im ersten Schritt, welche Infos sind denn verfügbar und dann, was wird damit gemacht?
Und dann, ja, Überleitung fragt den Staat, auch IFG-Anfragen stellen,
also irgendwie Infos vom Staat sich zu holen und zu erkämpfen und die zu veröffentlichen,
auch das, glaube ich, gehört dazu,
weil es eine Form von Räume schaffen ist und Möglichkeiten schaffen, für andere was zu tun.
Also ich glaube, man muss nicht den Anspruch an sich haben, jetzt allein irgendwie
loszugehen und die Demokratie zu retten, sondern es geht eher darum,
wie können wir gemeinsam so eine demokratische Infrastruktur stärken.
Aber du meinst im Prinzip jetzt so, also demokratische Infrastruktur generell,
aber auch die zwischenmenschliche demokratische Basis.
Ich fand das gerade sehr schön, auch deine Schilderung von was es bedeutet,
Begegnungsstätten und eine Klima- und eine Kultur für eine Gruppe kleineren
oder größeren Ausmaßes entweder einmalig oder auch idealerweise regelmäßig zu schaffen.
Das stimmt schon, dass das eine Wahnsinnswirkung
hat, was für Orte und Begegnungsmöglichkeiten man schafft.
Ja, also ich kenne das vom Kongress. Ich glaube, das kennen viele so.
Ich komme da rein irgendwie zum ersten Mal und ich kann da sein.
Also irgendwie dieses Gefühl, da so sein zu können, wie ich an anderen Orten
nicht so sein kann einfach.
Und solche Orte irgendwie zu haben, und das ist für unterschiedliche Leute,
sind es natürlich unterschiedliche Formen von Orten, aber sowas zu schaffen
ist, glaube ich, total wichtig.
An diesen Orten herrscht ja auch sehr regelmäßig eine Solidarität,
Freundlichkeit, Nachbarschaftshilfe, auch ein Interesse auf Begegnung vor,
das an den üblichen Orten der Zusammenkunft nicht unbedingt vertreten ist.
Sehen wir mal eine Shopping-Mall oder einen Bus, Flugzeugbahnen,
das sind alles eigentlich immer.
Also viele öffentliche Orte, an denen herrscht Distanziertheit bis zur Feindseligkeit.
Also ich empfinde es auch als einfach eine Unverschämtheit, wenn man in der
Bahn zum Beispiel angesprochen wird.
Nein, die und in die aber man kann ja offenbar nur durch eine Atmosphäre Menschen
da in so einen ganz anderen Flow bringen. Mhm.
Genau, und super, also weil du Shoppingmalls angesprochen hast,
die sind ja ursprünglich in den USA entstanden auf der Basis,
dass es dort, gerade so in eher ländlicheren Gebieten.
Gegenüberstätten gibt.
Genau, gibt dann halt nicht die Piazza, die es irgendwie in italienischen kleinen
Städten gibt, wo alle eh zusammenkommen und dann, was weiß ich, Boccia spielen.
Habe ich jetzt die Länder durcheinander gemacht? Ne, ich glaube das geht. Spiel mal da Boccia.
Ich glaube nur nicht auf der Piazza.
Shoppingmall. Also am Schluss geht es schon darum, dass du halt irgendwie Sachen einkaufst.
Und dann ist halt die Frage des Gegenmodells, wie schaffen wir solche Orte,
die auf Austausch gerichtet sind, wenn man sie haben will.
Also du musst jetzt auch nicht irgendwie hingehen und...
So ein Mitmachbus. Hi, komm rein.
Unser Podcast funktioniert ja auch so. Wir reden hier zwei Stunden über die
Rettung der Welt und dann erwarten wir natürlich auch, dass die Leute da ein T-Shirt kaufen.
Und dass die Leute mitmachen.
Ja, das auch.
Nackt werdet ihr die Welt vielleicht retten, aber frieren.
Okay, also Veranstaltungen und Orte, Räume definieren. Was ich auch übrigens
sehr spannend fand, ist, was du meintest mit Stickern.
Also Umgebung markieren.
In Berlin, also ich nehme jetzt an diesem Wettbewerb nicht teil.
Aber ich stelle natürlich fest, dass in Berlin viel darum geht,
ob der Kasten jetzt rot-weiß oder blau-weiß gestrichen ist.
Tim guckt nur und sagt, nein, diese blau-weißen Kästen, das ist einfach ein Dorn in seinem Auge.
Ich fände beides okay, solange es nicht schwarz-weiß-rot irgendwie ist.
Ähm,
Weil irgendwie definiert wird, welcher Spirit jetzt hier vorherrscht.
Ich fahre regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad aus Berlin raus und im Prinzip kannst du
den Abstand zu, sagen wir mal, ungefähr,
also wenn du die Grenze von Lichtenberg überschritten hast, erkennst du es daran,
dass es AfD-Plakate gibt.
Gibt, die weiteren Wege in Richtung Osten, und Berlin ist ja in jede Richtung Osten,
erkennst du die Distanz, wie weit du vom Fernsehturm weg bist,
daran, dass die AfD-Plakate immer niedriger kommen.
Du musst eigentlich nicht weit fahren, bis die komplett greifbar pflücken,
kannst du frei pflücken, AfD-Plakate, bis die dann irgendwann so besonders drapiert
im Vorgarten stehen oder so.
Das heißt, also diese Normalität, die man in einem Raum auf diese Weise gibt,
die definiert da sicherlich auch,
die setzt eine Kultur für die Menschen.
Also kauft euch eine ordentliche Sprühdose und macht rot-weiße Stromkästen und D-Slams für den Tim.
Gleichzeitig weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt ein, das können ja nur erste Schritte
sein. Es gibt ja Menschen, die machen das schon.
Ja, es ist auch immer die Frage, ist es jetzt Preaching to the Converted oder nicht?
Also jetzt kann ich natürlich lustig ein AfD-Wahlplakat ändern und da einen
guten Witz machen. Ich hätte einen.
Die tapezieren unser Land zuerst und da könnte man eigentlich wunderschön über
dieses unser einfach ein Russ kleben.
Habt ihr es gemacht? Schreibt uns in die Kommentare.
Ich frage mich dabei immer, ist das effizient? Also nutzt man seine Zeit damit sinnvoll?
Ich meine, wenn man zu nichts anderem bereit oder in der Lage ist, gut, meinetwegen.
Aber gerade jetzt so bei aktivistischen Gruppen,
wie zum Beispiel bei diesen Demonstrationen, es gibt ja verschiedenste Initiativen,
die sich gegründet oder wiedergefunden haben und die eben versuchen in irgendeiner
Form die Leute mitzunehmen und klarzumachen.
Und dann ist ja immer die Frage, okay, an wen wende ich mich jetzt?
Es gibt natürlich dann erstmal die Konvertierten. Also ich meine,
ich muss jetzt Linus nicht davon überzeugen, dass er nicht AfD wählt,
weil das macht er eh nicht so.
Und mein ganzes Umfeld ist auch irgendwie im Wesentlichen so,
dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich muss mich politisch nicht engagieren,
weil ich ohnehin in so einer Bubble bin, wo sie in der Regel eigentlich alle
noch alle beisammen haben.
Macht nur irgendwie im zwölften Jahr ein Podcast über Politik für euch nicht,
aber sonstiges Engagement Wir haben halt die 500.
Folge, aber Tim empfindet, muss ich hier nicht politisch engagieren Ja.
Also Ich kenn die ja alle nicht Ähm.
Ich denke, auch unser Zuhörerkreis ist im Wesentlichen sozusagen eher im Bereich
der Konvertierten. Ganz ehrlich.
Das mag Argumente liefern und deswegen reden wir jetzt ja auch gerade über dieses
Thema, weil wir ja uns Rüstzeug erarbeiten wollen, um Leute anzusprechen,
die eben jetzt in Kategorie 2 sind.
Und Kategorie 2 ist halt, sind sich bei allem nicht so sicher und das kann dann
halt so sein mit, ja, gehe ich überhaupt wählen, hat Wählen überhaupt,
das ist ja eigentlich die wertvollste Ressource, das sind ja Leute,
die sonst nicht wählen würden, aber denen auch nicht einfallen würde,
irgendwas Extremes zu wählen.
Aber die einfach mit einer SPD nichts anfangen können, weil SPD.
Und die mit einer CDU nichts anfangen können, weil CDU.
Und ja und vielleicht die Grünen, aber da haben sie irgendwas dagegen und die
Linken mögen sie auch nicht und dann stehen sie da und denken so,
bevor ich jetzt hier die Partei für Gesundheitsforschung wähle,
lasse ich es doch dann lieber ganz sein.
Und sich da sozusagen auch gar nicht entscheiden können, weil sie da in diesem
Ganzen, da wollen sie einfach nichts mit zu tun haben. Ich denke,
davon gibt es einfach viele Leute.
Das sind halt, müssen wir ja nur schauen, wie ist die Wahlbeteiligung,
wie viele hätten wählen können. Das ist eine riesige Ressource und ich finde,
das ist eigentlich die wertvollste Ressource.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich dann, wie gesagt, lustig machen und so die eigene
Bubble belustigen, indem man dann halt Wahlplakate interessant umgestaltet.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das besonders effizient ist.
Es fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, in Polen zur letzten Wahl gab es so eine Initiative,
habe ich das hier schon mal angesprochen, ich weiß es gerade nicht,
kann sein, wo dann sogar viele junge Leute sich wieder in ihren Heimatgemeinden,
aus denen sie mal hergekommen sind,
gemeldet haben bei ihren Eltern,
um dann dort wahlberechtigt zu sein.
Um sozusagen in diesen kritischen Wahlbezirken dann auch die fragilen Mehrheiten zu sichern,
um eben diesen politischen Umsturz, der glücklicherweise dann auch stattgefunden
hat in Polen, dann einzuleiten.
Das empfinde ich als eine ausgesprochen kreative und sinnvolle und zielgerichtete
Initiative, um mal so ein Beispiel zu nennen.
Ich würde noch mal kurz darauf zurückgehen, du hast auch, also diese Demonstrationen,
wir haben ja hier auch darüber gesprochen,
mit viel Werf und wenig Richtung,
drücken natürlich auch eine, bin ich ganz ehrlich, auch eine Hilflosigkeit teilweise aus.
Wo dann auch wir sind viele und wir werden jetzt aber dann kommt irgendwie nichts Konkretes und,
das spür ich ja auch wenn ich da bin,
gleichzeitig denke ich das Schlechteste was du tun kannst ist gar nichts und
dass du wirklich etwas dass du als einzelne Person,
jetzt irgendetwas machst, was wirklich einen fundamentalen Impact haben wird, da musst du schon,
ja, wir haben John Peters ja hier gehabt, da musst du schon irgendwie auch so viel Glück haben,
dass du halt diese eine Korrektivrecherche machst, die wirklich vielleicht so
groß ist und so eine Reichweite hat und vielleicht ein paar Menschen weckt,
dass man wirklich sagen kann, da habe ich jetzt etwas getan,
wo man sich vielleicht auch mal auf die Schulter klopft und sagt,
oder du schreibst ein ganzes Buch wie Arne dann kannst du auch hoffentlich sagen,
hier, also ich hab einen Beitrag geleistet, den ich gesagt habe,
wie andere einen leisten können ähm,
Aber dir wird am Ende nicht vergönnt sein, dass du eigenhändig den Faschismus gestoppt hast.
Also ich habe ja ein bisschen vorher von dieser...
Ich meinte jetzt nicht dir, vielleicht schon.
Also ich habe ein bisschen vorher von dieser Korrektivrecherche gewusst und
ich dachte mir, da wird doch niemand interessieren. Das war meine Einschätzung dazu.
Das war auch meine, ja.
Das ist ja nichts Neues, das wird niemanden hinterm Ofen vorlocken.
Und so geht es mir seit 20 Jahren, die ich so Zeug mache. Ich kann vorher nie
einschätzen, was funktioniert und was nicht.
Und deswegen weiß ich vorher auch nie, was jetzt effizient ist und was nicht in dem Sinne.
Ich mache und falle die ganze Zeit auf die Schnauze und dann lerne ich vielleicht
was daraus und nächstes Mal weiß ich es doch wieder nicht.
Deswegen würde ich glaube ich ähnlich sagen, also im Zweifel halt mal machen,
da gibt sich was draus oder halt nicht und dann kann ich wieder auf die Couch,
aber bis dahin versuche ich es doch einfach mal.
Ich würde nur sagen, dass das Problem ist, dass die meisten Leute Dinge mit
sehr viel weniger Ressourcen und auch sehr viel weniger Aussicht auf messbaren Impact machen als du.
Du hast die Möglichkeit, Aktionen
zu machen, dir eine Reichweite dafür zu verschaffen, Bücher zu schreiben,
Freiheitsfonds aufzusetzen, mit Böhmermann zusammenzuarbeiten.
Du hast da Ressourcen, wo man auch sagen kann, ja, du kannst wirklich vielleicht
auch mal massig daneben liegen und dann erreichst du nix.
Aber viele Leute haben noch nicht mal nennenswerte Ressourcen und noch nicht
mal eine Aussicht auf, dass sie wirklich überhaupt irgendeine Form von das habe
ich jetzt geschafft spüren anhand Selbstwirksamkeit.
Und gerade deswegen muss ja quasi eine Kultur geschaffen werden,
Wo es nicht mehr an der Einzelnen hängt.
Wo der Edeka-Eigentümer sagt, hier übrigens auch so mal gegen Nazis und dann
wird der angeschrien und dann erfährt er aber auch eine unmittelbare Welle der Solidarität,
weil man das zu einem Habitus macht, sich um Dinge zu kümmern und richtig zu leben.
Und was weiß ich, vielleicht ein T-Shirt zu tragen und eine Fahne im Vorgarten
zu haben und AfD-Plakate immer ungünstig dran hängen zu bleiben und was es alles irgendwie gibt,
um eine Kultur aufrechtzuerhalten.
Weil das, was ich irgendwie beobachte oder was ich mir einbilde wahrzunehmen,
ist halt ein Kulturwandel oder ein Kulturkämpfe und ich bin nach wie vor fest
davon überzeugt, dass es irgendwie auf meiner Seite echt angenehm sonnig und
fluffig ist und dass man auf dieser Seite auch wirklich das schönere Leben hat.
Das ist sowieso das, was ich bei diesen ganzen Nazis und so weiter nicht verstehe.
Das ist alles, das sind alles solche...
Das muss doch Kacke sein.
Ja, die sind alle so unlustig, die sind alle so verhärmt, die müssen immer die
ganze Zeit irgendwas hassen und Scheiße finden.
Den ganzen Tag beschäftigen die sich nur damit, was alles schlecht und doof ist.
Ganz im Gegensatz zu uns, die hier einen Gute-Nacht-Podcast machen.
Genau.
Ja, aber wir sind ja nicht vom Hass getragen, sondern wir sind ja sozusagen,
also 500 Folgen Hass Nee,
also ich kann ja sogar darüber noch lachen, überhaupt mal lachen zu können,
also das ist irgendwie nix, was ich da kulturell wahrnehme, ich meine,
das schau dir mal als maximales Extrembeispiel irgendwie diesen Donald Trump
an, ein Typ, der wahrscheinlich in seinem Leben noch nie einen richtigen Witz verstanden hat.
Weder verstanden noch gemacht hat.
Ja, naja. Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall auch so meine Schwierigkeiten bei vielen
Demonstrationen, die dann zum Beispiel gegen rechts sind.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass rechts unser Problem ist, sondern unser Problem ist Faschismus.
Und es gibt viele Leute, die sich als rechts verstehen, aber keine Gefahr für
diese Gesellschaft darstellen, die in dem Moment sich halt wahrscheinlich davon
dann auch nicht abgeholt fühlen.
Aber du hast natürlich schon recht. Also so eine Kultur des Widerstands generell
aufrecht zu erhalten durch jegliche Maßnahme ist auf jeden Fall auch kein Fehler.
Deinen Gedanken noch ein bisschen weiter geführt. Man muss sich natürlich schon
überlegen, wo man die Linie zieht und wie man sich positioniert.
Ja, wenn ich, wäre es so, ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass ich den Gedanken
so teile, aber wäre es so, dass ich sage, gegen rechts ist etwas,
was potenziell den Leuten ins Auge sticht, die ich eigentlich überzeugen möchte,
weil die Antifa Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg brauche ich nicht mehr zu überzeugen.
Da muss ich natürlich irgendwie gucken, dass ich denen auch ein gutes Bild abgebe,
um sie irgendwie auch für meine Seite zu überzeugen. Das ist etwas,
was vielen Leuten schwerfällt.
Aber ich glaube, ich würde tatsächlich denken, also ein demokratischer Habitus,
das Zusammenkommen, das nett zueinander sein, das positive Signale zeigen,
Solidarität zeigen, dass das sehr viel weiter spricht als Abgrenzungen.
Ja, also das positive Beispiel, das freundlich sein, positive Überraschungen
im Leben anderer Menschen sein.
Nur nicht, wenn du in der Bahn sitzt, dann nicht.
Also in der Bahn auch, aber wo wirklich alles endet, ist im Ruheabteil.
Okay, ja.
Da bin ich eng.
Da bin ich konservativ.
Aber wir haben noch,
vielleicht noch die Frage, wenn wir uns dann irgendwann auf den Staat nicht
mehr verlassen können oder so, welche Handlungsoptionen hat man denn noch so?
Prepping.
Prepping for future.
Prepper, das sind doch die, die sich im Keller mit Dosenravioli einschließen.
Oder dann sogar noch Munition vielleicht bunkern und die dann auch nochmal mitnehmen,
sagt das öffentliche Bild.
Aber Prepping, ja, gute Kurve noch, oder?
Noch nicht den Kommentar schreiben, Leute. Hört mir erstmal zu.
Wir brauchen nämlich auch noch.
Also erstmal ist es ja so eine Idee von Prepping.
Wir bereiten uns auf einen Ernstfall vor, wo ein Staat und Strukturen zusammenbricht
und wir wollen dafür vorsorgen.
Total sinnvoll. Die Frage ist dann aber, wie man das macht und das,
was man in der Öffentlichkeit vor allem mitbekommt, ist so eine Form des individualistischen Preppings.
Also ich schaue, dass ich überlebe, danach ist irgendwie Kampf des Stärkeren.
Ich schaue, dass ich jetzt Sachen lerne und vielleicht noch meine Familie und
dann ziehen wir los und leben im Wald und überleben.
Und das ist jetzt eine Vorstellung, also von mir aus kann man das machen,
wenn man nicht dazu dann irgendwelches scheiß menschenfeindliches Gedankengut hat.
Aber für mich ist das nicht attraktiv. Was ich interessant finde und was ich
bei sowas wichtig finde, ist so eine Form von solidarischem Prepping sich zu überlegen.
Also ich nenne das jetzt Prepping for Future, um das schön anschlussfähig zu haben.
Und da geht es dann eher darum, also an sich Vorräte zu schaffen,
aber eben nicht nur Medikamente und Essen, sondern Vorräte an Liebe, also Vorräte an Liebe.
Beziehung zu schauen, was für Netzwerke kann ich aufbauen,
was für Verbindungen kann ich schaffen von Menschen, die dann im Ernstfall zusammenstehen
und da ist dann letztlich, glaube ich, diese Diskussion um Räume,
die wir hatten, ein Teil davon.
Ist dann die Frage, rede ich vielleicht doch mit meinen NachbarInnen oder doch
nicht, aber das gehört, glaube ich, auch mit rein in dieses Prepping,
also was ist denn eigentlich in so einem,
Moment da Und wie kann ich mich auch um Leute kümmern, die vielleicht allein
dann weniger gut klarkommen als ich.
Und dazu spielt dann auch rein, das was ich vorhin meinte mit ja am Wahlabend
vielleicht ein paar Leuten Bescheid sagen, hey ich denke an dich,
dir muss es jetzt echt scheiße gehen, es tut mir leid.
Das alles würde ich so zusammenfassen unter Prepping for Future und ich habe
den Eindruck, diesen Prepping Begriff, den sollten wir vielleicht ein bisschen
reclaimen oder die Idee vom Prepping.
Okay, aber Prepping heißt ja, ich bereite mich jetzt sozusagen auf schlechte Zeiten vor.
Genau, und idealerweise kommen die dann gar nicht.
Dann hast du eine ganze Menge Liebe im Keller.
Ja genau, also ich glaube ganz viele dieser Maßnahmen, über die man spricht,
die machen es dann besser.
Also wie irgendwie dieser Witz im Zusammenhang mit der Klimakrise.
Ja was ist denn, wenn es irgendwie die doch eigentlich gar nicht gibt und die
doch… die doch eine schöne.
Welt geschaffen haben ja.
Genau und so ist es glaube ich da grundsätzlich oh jetzt ist die AfD nicht an
der Macht, aber ich habe viele Freundinnen gewonnen na gut.
Ja, wo machen wir das? Zum Beispiel am 31.
August in der Urania im Humboldtsaal.
Hast du ein Geheimnis oder neben Besuche den Kongress oder entsprechende Veranstaltungen,
wie bootstrappt man sowas denn?
Also ich meine, wir in Berlin könnten vielleicht auch sagen,
wir wohnen jetzt auch lange genug hier, ausreichend sozial verwurzelt,
dass wir da jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr preppen brauchen.
Wir haben das vielleicht auch schon gemacht, vielleicht auch gar nicht mit dem
Ziel, sondern weil wir einfach so gelebt haben.
Wie preppt denn jetzt so ein Jugendlicher auf dem Dorf?
Indem er sich überlegt, wann bin ich 18 und kann nach Berlin gehen und dann
count und sich bastelt Also dazu bin ich glaube ich dann ein bisschen zu sehr
Stadtkind um das in einer Weise überzeugend zu sagen, dass Leute dann,
in dieser Situation auch das überzeugend fänden. Ich glaube,
das was ich da an Ideen habe.
Bezieht sich zu sehr auf deine Realität.
Auf meine Umwelt und da muss ich dann so weit vage bleiben, dass ich sage,
ja es geht darum um Gleichgesinnte zu finden.
Und da gibt es dann, glaube ich, immer wieder Versuche. Ich habe den Eindruck,
sowas wie nebenan.de oder so ist dann schon auch der Versuch. Das gibt es ja überall.
Wenn es in physischen Räumen schwieriger ist, weil da irgendwie wenig Leute
sind wie man selbst, dann versucht
man es halt eher über Digitale und da findet man dann die erstmal.
Es ist auf eine Weise, also ich glaube, dass dieser Zusammenhalt und sonst was, Nachbarschaftshilfe,
schon so ein Kit ist,
der sehr, sehr viel in einer Gesellschaft ermöglicht.
Also das glaube ich tatsächlich auch. Ich glaube, es gibt so eine Tendenz,
Gruppen sehr stark über gemeinsame Identität zu finden und das ist sinnvoll
und richtig und ich mache das ja auch,
aber Gruppen über gemeinsame Bedürfnisse zu finden und darüber,
dass man von anderen Menschen Bedürfnisse denen nachkommt.
Das ist das, was du dann mit Nachbarschaftshilfe bezeichnest und dann vielleicht
irgendwann, also jetzt ohne Aussicht, dass ich das unbedingt brauche,
aber dann irgendwann vielleicht auch ein Bedürfnis habe, was andere dann erfüllen können.
Also Gruppen auch zu bilden über Bedürfnisse, glaube ich, ist da ein guter Anfang.
Was für Bedürfnisse fallen dir da so ein, als Beispiel?
Was ich krass fand vor Monaten, das sind dann bestimmte Communities,
Aquare-Communities, die das so mitbekommen, ist, dass es Lieferengpässe gab,
so bei HIV-Medikamenten.
Super krass. Also was einfach unmittelbare Auswirkungen hatte auf einzelne Leute,
die diese Medikamente brauchten.
Und da haben sich in diesem Umfeld dann Gruppen gebildet, die geschaut haben,
okay, die Strukturen, die jetzt diese Medikamente liefern, die klappen nicht.
Wie können wir denn selbst organisieren, dass wir an diese Medikamente kommen?
Und das ist voll Prepping, so unmittelbares Prepping im Prinzip in dem Moment.
Das heißt Bedürfnisse nach Gesundheit, sehr, sehr unmittelbar.
Gut, aber das ist jetzt ein allgemeines Beispiel, aber jetzt konkret auf die,
wie verhindert man entweder einen AfD-Wahlsieg oder wie verhindert man negative
Auswirkungen eines AfD?
Ich glaube das was Arne gerade gesagt hat bezog sich eher darauf du bildest
eine Gruppe basierend auf Identität, wir sind jetzt was weiß ich die Männergruppe oder die,
also wo es über ein Zugehörigkeitsgefühl geht sag es.
Alte weiße Männer.
Keine Ahnung was du für Gruppen machst und,
dann gibt es du bist.
Da auch drin.
Ich bin noch nicht so weit.
Mittelalt.
Und dann gibt es die, dass dieses Bedürfnisse, also ich habe das jetzt so verstanden,
dass sich in einer, vielleicht auch dann eher einer Zweckgemeinschaft,
die sich nicht unbedingt darüber definiert, gleiche Identitäten zu haben,
sondern die eine Bedürfnisgemeinschaft bildet.
Und das muss jetzt nicht ein einziges Bedürfnis sein, das können ja einfach sehr viele sein.
Also Nachbarschaftshilfe, ich brauch mal Salz, hast du mal Butter,
ach komm ich fahr eh morgen einkaufen, ich nehm dich mit.
Wodurch ja für alle Beteiligten eine sehr große Ressource entsteht.
Also wenn man mal so merkt, dass man, was man in so einem Freundeskreis,
in einem gesunden Freundeskreis, der hat ja in der Regel nicht eine gemeinsame Identität.
Erfüllt, aber regelmäßig wenn die Situation eintritt eine Person von uns,
hat ein Bedürfnis wo wir gerade unterstützen können und es uns leicht fällt
das ist doch die Idee von Solidarität und ich glaube darauf also so hatte ich
das jetzt verstanden zu sagen Gruppen eher als Bedürfnis,
Netzwerke als Identitäts Homogenität.
Was gleichzeitig eine Herausforderung ist, glaube ich, weil es viele Menschen gibt,
die in irgendeiner Weise Diskriminierung oder Gewalt erfahren,
dadurch, dass sie sind, wie sie sind, dass sie aussehen, wie sie aussehen oder so.
Und für die es dann nochmal schwieriger ist zu sagen, also wo ich das auch sehr
gut nachvollziehen kann, dass man dann dementsprechend sich die Gruppen sucht
und es dementsprechend dann auch eine größere Überwindung ist,
glaube ich, so vorzugehen.
Und das ist dann halt eine Frage, ob man das machen kann und will,
dann halt mit den NachbarInnen zu reden, obwohl man die irgendwie komisch findet.
Zumindest die Schwarz-Rot-Reiße-Flagge im Vorgarten ist irgendwie so echt gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Na, da muss man aber natürlich dann auch klare Grenzen ziehen, aber...
Gut. Ich habe so den Eindruck, wir haben das jetzt so ein bisschen zusammengefegt bekommen.
Wir haben uns nicht so sehr über netzpolitische Maßnahmen unterhalten.
Demokratie ist auch Netzpolitik.
Netzpolitik ist auch Demokratie. Ich mag es auch, dass man es mal grundsätzlich
diskutiert hat, weil es ja auch der Takt des Grundgesetzes ist.
Und deswegen haben wir jetzt mal grundsätzlich was diskutiert.
Grundsätzliches zum Grundgesetz.
Damit bleibt uns darauf hinzuweisen, dass wir selbstverständlich den Links zum
Vorbestellen oder dann bald Bestellen deines Buches in den Shownotes haben und
euch wirklich motivieren möchten,
das dann auch zu kaufen oder illegal herunterzuladen.
Also es gibt am Schluss eine Danke-Seite und da das letzte Danke geht an Sci-Hub
und Library Genesis in meinem Buch, weil ich sehr davon profitiert habe, das will ich nur sagen.
Nein, aber dieses Buch zu lesen, ich denke, das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger
Beitrag in der politischen Auseinandersetzung dieser Zeit.
Von jemandem geschrieben, der ja nun wirklich dieses System verstanden hat,
muss ich mir mal vorstellen.
Also allein das ist ja schon beeindruckend und würde mich sehr freuen,
wenn dieses Buch ein großer Erfolg wird und auch die Ideen, die da drin sind.
Angeboten werden, nochmal über sich selber hinauswachsen.
Ein so großer Erfolg wird, dass wir dann gar nicht über die Konsequenzen reden müssen, die dort,
dargestellt werden.
Das Buch, hoffen wir, dass das Buch so ein großer Erfolg wird,
dass die Leute irgendwann sagen, meine Güte, was ein Schwachmann.
Mach es, mach es.
Mann, Mann, Mann. Die goldenen Zwanziger. Da ging's los.
Arne, vielen, vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Dass du gekommen bist und mit uns geredet hast.
Wann machst du nächstes Mal einen Monat Urlaub? Nur, dass wir wissen,
wann das nächste Buch kommt.
Ich hab schon die Idee. Ich rede gerade mit dem Verlag fürs nächste.
Aber dann darfst du wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht sagen, worüber.
Um eine sehr konkrete Maßnahme davon und die dann in Tiefe.
Es wird es geht auch um Liebe ein bisschen und um Abwesenheit von Liebe.
Also ich dachte Generalstreik, dann gehen sie heute nicht zur Arbeit und morgen auch nicht.
Ein leeres Buch, weil ich Streik gemacht habe. Das ist immer noch mein Lieblingsworkshop.
Ich glaube, das war beim Helokongress mal irgendwann.
Das war der Workshop zu Blaumachen.
Und es kam einfach niemand. Es war richtig gut. Es war ein richtig guter Workshop.
Okay, ich bin gespannt. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich der Arztroman zur Revolution.
Wir sagen Tschüss.
Das sagen wir.
Sagen wir das? Ja, wir sagen das. Tschüss. Tschüss Arne. Tschüss alle. Bis bald. Das war's.
Ciao, ciao.